[Musique]
David guireot bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle surview nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
sucintement David guireud 32 ans je suis
député France insoumis de la 8e
circonscription du Nord j'habite à roubé
ma circonscription c'est roubé watrolo
ancien bastion du textile français on
habillit toute l'Europe à l'époque et
euh et j'ai été député j'ai été élu
député il y a quelques années c'était en
2022 lors des premières élections avant
la dissolution et réélu député là il y a
un an à peine suite à la dissolution
d'Emmanuel Macron qu'est-ce que vous
faisiez avant alors moi j'ai un profil
assez classique en gros j'ai fait des
études histoire science politique à la
Sorbonne votre garage quoi ouais c'est
non non non ah non l'histoire alors la
science politique peut-être mais moi
l'histoire j'ai j'ai adoré ça j'ai adoré
ça parce que c'était pas c'était pas
tant sur les dates et les figures mais
en terme de de discipline
d'apprentissage c'est-à-dire de savoir
raisonner d'apprendre à construire ton
raisonnement à faire une disserte à
faire un commentaire de texte et cetera
moi j'ai eu vraiment une vraie
discipline là-dessus en plus de la
culture générale ça ça prend pas en
seconde ça une
dissertation tu tu commences vraiment à
rentrer dans le dur quand vous avant moi
j'ai été collaborateur parlementaire
donc j'ai travaillé mais j'ai été
salarié du politique j'ai une
trajectoire avant non enfin j'ai fait
j'ai fait des stages j'ai fait des
petits boulot et cetera mais j'ai pas eu
une expérience tu vois de chantier ou de
enfin si chantier j'ai payé mes études
avec les chantiers mais mais mes
vacances pardon mes études j'avais la
chance d'avoir mes parents mais non je
suis un je suis un profil très classique
de salarié du politique voilà faut
l'assumer hein je me prends pas pour ce
que je suis combi vous gagnez en tant
que député non en tant que sportif de
haut niveau non parce que quand j'étais
collaborateur parlementaire j'étais à
2000 et là je suis comme tous les
députés donc à 5000 5000 nets par mois
ça c'est mon indemnité parlementaire des
avantages en nature chauffeur service de
police protection au personnes non j'ai
rien de ça service de police je le je
leurisi malheureusement parce que depuis
que j'ai pris position pas mal sur la
Palestine j'ai eu quelques enemmerdes
mais non non on a des avantages si tu
veux on a une enveloppe parlementaire si
c'est ça que tuappelles avantage mais en
fait c'est pour exercer ton boulot quoi
donc ce qui peut êtreer la Pte des gens
autour de vous c'est un peu plus dur
j'ai pas le forfait pour ça en fait le
le 50 % de mon enveloppe parlementaire à
moi c'est ma permanence voilà c'est pour
recevoir les gens à
roubé dans le centre de roubé on on
franchement on prend cher alors j'ai
choisi d'avoir une belle permanence
parce que j'accueille des gens et en
plus c'est là que je fais aussi maises
j'aime bien faire des compte-rendus de
mon mandat ou autre donc j'ai besoin
d'accueillir allez 70 personnes quoi et
sans compter la politique vous vous
destinez à quel type de de profession
alors moi j'ai fait donc ça c'était ma
licence donc je t'ai parlé d'histoire et
cetera passionnant tu m'as coupé un peu
vite parce que enfin on peut se oui on
peut se tuttoyer avec plaisir
euh c'est plus dur quand on se tuoit
faut faire attention c'est pas grave
mais moi j'ai j'ai vu beaucoup de gens
vous voyez avec un air carnaasser
euh non je disais sur l'histoire il y
avait quand même des choses
passionnantes ça m'a même poussé à faire
des voyages certains voyages j'avais des
profs par exemple qui étaient habités he
sur l'histoire de la Révolution j'ai eu
Boucheron qui est un profil très
socialdémocrate he Boucheron vous avez
voyagé un peu
alors j'ai commencé vraiment à
voyager vraiment après ma majorité mais
bien après quoi c'estàd je suis très peu
sorti d'Europe quand j'étais petit et
j'ai commencé à voyager tu vois à
prendre l'avion et cetera vraiment après
mes 20 25 ans même voilà et maintenant
j'ai j'ai quand même un peu voyagé et
maintenant j'ai envie et ce que je fais
dans mes voyages c'est que bon j'essaie
de faire un grand voyage tous les allez
3 4 5 ans quel budget ça dépend là quel
sac à dos ou quel 5 étoiles ni l'un ni
l'autre euh je suis pas fan de camping
honnêtement mais je suis pas obligé
d'aller dans un grand truc après c'est
la destination si tu vas à New York tu
vas casquer si tu vas dans des campagnes
italiennes ou autres bon si tu vas avec
ta compagne tu prends un hôtel sympa
pour toi et ta compagne ça peut coûter
un peu cher mais c'est quand même des
prix qui sont beaucoup moins chers et
après ce que j'aime bien faire c'est
aussi la France en fait le Soudan le
Soudan c'est pas mal hein le Soudan
c'est pas mal mais c'est pas dans les
destinations non mais là je suis là
vraiment par exemple le dernier voyage
que je fais en France un petit peu là
sur les congés parce que j'ai peu de
temps en fait nos vacances elles on il
faut il faut bosser pour ce tarif là
ouais bien sûr non mais en fait nos
vacances ont explosé en juillet dernier
par exemple tu vois avec la dissolution
et cetera il y il y a moi j'ai des pieds
d'avion mais par exemple les châteaux de
la Loire ou ces trucs là ouais
j'aimerais bien aller en Alsace les
château de la Loire c'est magnifique
c'est magnifique les sont super sympas
et tuas un terroir et ça pour le C on
par il faut qu'on RRE dans le dur la
commission des finances ouais commission
des finances tu as appris quoi quel est
ton ton point de vue sur ce qui s'est
passé ça va nous emmener où est-ce qu'il
va y avoir des condamnations alors
attends on va reprendre tout commission
des finances moi en gros j'ai bossé pour
Éric coqurel quand tu me demandais que
tu as reçu il y a pas longtemps qui
était qui est aujourd'hui président de
la commission des finances moi sur ce
que j'ai appris là tu es sur le déficit
en fait par rapport au je suis sûr
pourquoi on a mis milliard de dettes en
plus ouais alors moi j'ai bossé sur ça
depuis depuis que je suis élu et je me
suis rendu compte de choses j'ai mis du
temps à men rendre compte
mais sur une desésévolutions profonde du
quinquena d'Emmanuel Macron si tu veux à
gauche on a tendance à dire et on a
raison d'ailleurs que quelque part la
marque du quinquen Macron c'est des
centaines de milliards d'euros d'aide
aux entreprises dilapider et
cetera moi je suis d'accord avec ça mais
il y a un truc qu'on a pas qu'on a mis
du temps à comprendre que moim-même j'ai
mis du temps à comprendre à expliquer
c'est comment ça se fait parce que si tu
vois là là on est on est en train
comment se faitce mais comment se faitce
que on soit en déficit budgétaire alors
qu'en fait moi ce que j'ai regardé en
premier dans les documents budgétaires
c'est c'est les recettes issues des
impôts on nous dit par exemple tu vois
Barnier il tombe Michel Barnier l'ancien
Premier ministre qui tombe sur une
motion de censure il tombe parce qu'en
gros on résiste à une sorte de coupe de
allez 30 milliards d'euros mais moi
quand tu regardes les documents
budgétaires tu te rends compte que
l'État a jamais été aussi riche l'État a
jamais récolté autant d'argent issu des
impôts de son histoire tu parles de la
TVA là pas que alors c'est la mais c'est
vrai que c'est la TVA qui qui qui prend
une part considérable mais la TVA c'est
le premier impôt des Français enfin
c'est le premier impôt de l'État et euh
si tu veux les ressources elles passent
en gros quand Macron prend le pouvoir on
est à environ 150 milliards d'euros de
recett de la TVA et aujourd'hui allez
l'année dernière c'est 219 je crois 219
milliards frappé en pleine tronche et
donc je me suis dit c'est bizarre parce
que je vois qu'il y a 219 milliards
d'euros donc des recettes considérables
en plus pour l'État mais dans les
documents budgétaires de l'État on on
stagne depuis quelques années on stagne
à 95 milliards 100 milliards d'euros de
recett c'estàdire je me dis il manque
100 milliards sur les 200 milliards
d'euros de recettees qu'on récupère de
la TVA je n'en retrouve que 100
milliards environ depuis plusieurs
années là dans le budget de l'État donc
je me dit où est-ce que c'est parti et
avant de t'expliquer où est-ce que c'est
parti faut faire un petit retour parce
qu'il y a quelque chose qu'il faut bien
comprendre sur comment est organiser le
système fiscal français tu as trois
budgets en France tu en a pas qu'un nous
on a tendance à parler du budget de
l'État et c'est vrai qu' on a tendance à
tout mettre là-dessus mais plus gros
budget c'est la protection sociale 800
milliards d'euros autant te dire que là
les enjeux liés à la privatisation de la
protection sociale et cetera c'est un
marché de 800 milliards d'euros faut
bien làdessus oui oui c'est retraite oui
y a de la protection sociale toute la
protection sociale ensuite c'estq et
cetera en fait ça va au-delà de la
cécule la protection sociale ensuite tu
as le budget de l'État donc là tu es sur
des bon ça dépend des années parce qu'en
fait tu as 250 et quelques milliards
d'euros de recettes et on dépense tu es
sur du 300 milliards d'euros et quelques
vu qu'on est en déficit et puis tu as le
budget des collectivités locales
celui-là on a tendance à l'oublier
Région Département commune ces trois
budgets ils sont séparés à la base
évidemment il y a des transferts
d'argent entre les trois ça arrive hein
mais le truc pour moi fondamental
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est pas les aides
aux entreprises c'est que là il se passe
un truc dans la manière dont il y a de
l'argent qui passe du budget de l'État à
d'autres budgets et pourquoi faire et
moi en fait ce que je me suis rendu
compte quand je me suis demandé où
étaient passé ces 100 milliards d'euros
de TVA qui est une somme mais pareil là
on parle du là là en ce moment là on est
avec des petites notes ouais j'ai des
notes j'aime sur lesig c'est ça ah bah
François Ruffin t'a prévenu non mais
c'est même pas François Ruffin moi tous
mes plateaux et tous mes médias je les
prépare sérieusement en fait voilà moi
c'est un parti prix que j'ai pris même
quand j'étais Mino mes premiers médias
je les faisais je passais 1 heure et de
à réviser mes trucs avant de débarquer
sur un média alors j'avais des notes
souvent c'est des notese ça venir ici
euh j'ai commencé pour être honnête j'ai
relu quelques livres parce que je
voulais avoir quelques notions mais en
fait ça me servira à rien je pense ce
soir mais je relisais un ou deux livres
sur la guerre sociale en France pour
avoir quelques bases théoriques mais en
fait ça me gonfle moi les auteurs
libéraux néolibéraux je les mets tous
dans la classe dans une casse bullshit
dans ma tête j'arrive pas c'est une
erreur peut-être non je vais y revenir
mais ça m'intéresse la cohérence du
projet capitaliste C néolibéral mais si
tu veux bon les les les les théories sur
l'optimisation le marché machin bon tu
vois au bout d'un moment c'est bon quoi
tu lâches mais donc j'ai lu ça et puis
je me suis préparé je dirais il y a j'ai
commencé vraiment hier matin pour
remettre tout à jour mais moi ça fait un
an que je bosse sur ça donc euh là c'est
juste je me dis comment je l'explique
aux gens dans un format de 2hur qui est
pas sur BFM 15 minutes ù moi je sais que
j'arrive bon c'est la bagarre quoi là
c'est pas la bagarre c'est un format un
peu différent donc j'is besoin de savoir
comment j'amenis tout ça tu as déjà
regardé quelques émissions ouais bah
déjà j'ai vu celle
d'éicis ouais cqurel je crois que j'ai
vu du to j'ai vu j'en ai vu plusieurs de
tes émissions mais militaire un peu non
non pas trop renseignement du diplomate
du diplomate j'en ai vu je sa plus mais
j'en ai vu chinois peut-être le russe le
taiwanais non non un français j'ai vu un
français du Vedrine Vedrine j'ai
vu bjour bonne année tu veux connais pas
mais et donc voilà je me demandais un
peu tout ça donc trois budgets il faut
que les gens vraiment ils retiennent ça
il y a trois budgets différents
euh et donc il manque 100 milliards et
en fait pour moi la marque du macronisme
c'est pas ça ça ne se résume pas aux
aides public aux entreprises quelque
part il a augmenté les montants mais si
tu veux François Hollande faisait pareil
Nicolas Sarkozi avait commencé aussi bon
tu vois c'est un classique de la
politique française de se dire la
politique de l'OF faut qu'on bombarde
d'argent les entreprises les grandes
boîtes ce qui ch
c'est comment il a financé ça Macron en
fait moi c'est ça qui me et et en fait
ce qui est ce qui est fantastique c'est
que c'est passé au travers de toute la
classe politique mais c'est vrai que
c'est un sujet si tu fais pas gaffe tu
t'en rends pas compte mais ça commence à
venir je suis assez content parce que ça
commence à monter c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
a fait de l'argent de la TVA qui a
jamais été aussi haut et donc je vais te
prendre un par un les trucs collectivité
locale collectivité locale on a fait
sous Macron quelque chose c'est qu'on a
supprimé trois impôts dont deux qui
existaient depuis la Révolution
française he la taxe d'habitation et la
contribution sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises taxe d'habitation c'était je
crois c'était la taxe communale ou la
contribution
1791 après ça a eu d'autres noms hein et
puis la CVE pareil c'était je l'avais
noté quelque part mais c'était la la la
patente je l'ai patente en 1791 euh on a
supprimer ces deux impôts là en se
disant bon faut donner un coup de pouce
tu vois la consommation et cetera faut
savoir quand on a supprimé la taxe
d'habitation c'est vrai qu'il y a des
classes moyennes qui l'a payé qui sont
dit à chouette je paye un peu moins mais
en fait la vérité c'est que par exemple
les 15 à 20 % des classes qui payaient
la taxe d'habitation les plus pauvres la
payit pas parce qu'en fait c'est en
fonction de ton revenu il y avait des
conditions et cetera tu peux avoir des
baisses aussi sur ce que tu devais payer
de taxe d'habitation par contre les 20 %
les plus riches eux ils ont bénéficié
plein pot de la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation en gros les 20 % les plus
riches c'est la Cour des comptes qui dit
ça ont bénéficié de des des gains de 50
% de la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation on est riche à partir de
combien en France bah si ça dépend de
tes déciles tu regardes ça dépend du
décil que tu regardes moi 5000 € je fais
partie sûrement des 5 % les plus non pas
0,1 mais je dois être dans les 5 % les
plus riches à mon avis je j'ai pas fait
de mais à mon avis je suis dans les 5 %
facile euh
ce qui est pas énorme en soi mais après
tu as un un fossé énorme en fait entre
les 1 % et les 01 et puis les
01 je reviens sur mes collectivités
locales on a supprimé ces impôts là bon
comme je t'ai dit c'est des impôts
notamment la taxe d'habitation en fait
qu'on profitait plus au plus riches
c'est pas vrai que c'était que les
classes moyennes c'est vrai un petit peu
hein je l'admets hein mais voilà et ce
qui est marrant c'est comment on a
financé ça en fait parce que le grand
truc c'est on a dit on supprime cet
impôt les gens payent plus sauf qu'en
fait si tu fais fait ça sans compenser
les collectivités locales elles ont plus
de sources de financement elles cass ça
se casse la gueule c'est plus possible
donc l'État était obligé de le financer
et en fait il a financer comment avec
l'argent de la TVA c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait il a fait passer un impôt qui était
financé sur la base depuis la Révolution
tu vois sur la base de là où tu habites
sur une base territoriale ou sur la base
de là où tu produis territorialement
dans ta commune et cetera maintenant
c'est le consommateur il y a un
changement complet de paradigme tu vois
c'est le consommateur qui qui finance
l'extinction de ces de ces impôts donc
ce que tu payes au cadit de supermarché
tu en as une partie qui vient financer
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
pour moi ça n'a aucun sens tu rajoutes à
ça des trucs pareil qui ont été financés
par la TVA comme la redevance
audiovisuel c'est la TVA ça a été
compensé aussi en fait l'impôt n'a pas
disparu il a été compensé par l'argent
de la TVA et tu te retrouve en fait dans
une
situation où les collectivités locales
leur source de financement principale
c'est
plus ce qui peut se passer sur ta
commune sur ton département sur ta
région sur la commune encore un peu mais
c'est cet argent de la TVA tu j'avais
pris un graphique parce que moi alors je
sais pas si on va le voir bien mais si
si on a une très bonne tu vois la flèche
donc en fait la courbe noire c'est donc
ça c'est les principales recettes
fiscales des collectivités ton papier
j'ai ma camera woman qui va mettre un
petite mise au point et alors si tu
regardes bien en 2020 il y a une flèche
qui B dit d'un coup quoi c'est les c'est
les produits de la TVA dû à l'inflation
non c'est ce que l'État a donné en TVA
aux collectivité tu vois dans le
financement ça ça pose un problème donc
là tu es en train de me décrire un effet
de manche de Macron ouais bon tous les
politiciens font
ça déshabille Paul pour réhabiller
Jacques ouais mais ça prend des
proportions inquiétantes c'est que tu
sais moi je j'ai une vision de
l'organisation de l'état où la commune
est administrée librement et cetera et
en plus ça va poser des problèmes
bientôt parce que que tu le veuilles ou
non quand tu as des impôts qui sont
comme celui sur la propriété foncière ou
autre c'est des impôts qui sont
territorialisés c'est-à-dire ils sont
ancrés dans la réalité de ton territoire
ces impôts là tu
vois là on les a fait disparaître mais
on les a compensé mais donc en fait on a
figé la répartition de capô à un instant
T c'est le moment où supprime on
compense un territoire qui reçoit de
l'argent aujourd'hui de la TVA en
compensation OK mais si sa population
elle vieillit il aura pas les mêmes
besoins qu'un territoire où la
population elle est amenée à rajunir
elle a plus de besoin d'investissement
par exemple donc en fait les territoires
par exemple les plus jeune si la
répartition elle change pas ils vont se
retrouver considérablement défavorisés
en fait par cette réribu par cette par
cette répartition par jeu de manche et
en plus de ça moi ce que j'ajoute en
plus dans la discussion mais je vais
parler aussi avec la SCU parce que ça
c'était le premier pan tu vois c'est la
première
carotte c'est qu'en fait moi ce que
j'observe c'est que si tu veux l'État
est en train de mettre ses pattes sur la
gestion des collectivités locales parce
que quand tu payes tu décides quand tu
payes tu décides jusqu'ici l'état il
payait pas voilà ou alors il y avait des
mécanismes de solidarité et cetera mais
là c'est pas juste qu'il paye c'est que
ça prend des proportions tu tu l'as vu
la flèche sur le graphique qui monteant
ça prend des proportion et quand tu
payes tu décides donc tu vas pouvoir
décider à la place des collectivités
locales de de tu vois de mettre la main
dans leur financement de pouvoir dire
des choses ou de dire bah en fait juste
on a plus assez d'argent ou avant les
élections lui dire attention bah c'est
ce qui se passe en ce moment regarde
onand un effort aux collectivité locale
alors on a dit 5 milliards bon les élus
locaux il ils réagissent aujourd'hui si
tu veux cette compensation quelque part
par exemple pour les communes les
communes elles s'y retrouvent dans la
compensation mais attention c'est plus
elles qui reçoivent l'argent c'est
l'état et moi je suis issu d'une
tradition politique ou si tu veux dans
ma famille politique l'État et mon père
é au PS mon père était au PS alors ma
famille politique je parle de LFI moi
j'ai fait un autre choixin mais mais
l'état si tu veux je m'en méfie aussi un
peu pourquoi l'État c'est N
non non l'État s'est construit l'État a
une logique propre l'État peut être
utile sur des domaines de cohésion
nationale mais moi j'ai pas envie qu'il
soit présent dans toutes nos vies et sur
tous les domaines qui le regardent pas
les collectivités ça le regarde pas
forcément tout le temps
libéral je suis socialiste dans l'âme
mais en fait parfait je me méfie non
mais tu as raison moi j'ai une méfiance
de l'État et maintenant je vais te dire
ce qu'il font avec la
sécu si tu veux la SCU
telle qu'elle a été inventée en 45 à la
base l'État n'était pas dans la gestion
de la
SC en 45 le patronat avait collaboré
donc
déjà les Allemands ouais petite ambiance
de travail c'est plutôt les syndicats
qui gèent la discussion avec l'État qui
est là le
gaulisme puis bon l'URSS qui met une
petite pression sur l'paule aussi du
patronat français he sur les communistes
aussi et les communistes ressortent du
conflit sont tous armés enfin tu vois
bon il y a une ambiance de [__] qui est
un peu différente euh en 45 dans la
gestion de la sécurité sociale donc qui
est le plus gros magot d'argent beaucoup
plus que le budget de l'État dans la
gestion de la sécurité sociale qui c'est
qui gère c'est globalement les syndicats
avec une partie du patronat pour une
raison simple ceux qui côtisent c'est
les patrons et les travailleurs c'est
pas l'état l'état il a rien à faire
là-dedans dans cette discussion il
apporte zéro
donc les syndicats les travailleurs il
gèrent c'est les syndicats de
travailleurs qu' on la plus grosse
partie des pourcentages de voix et cette
tendance elle commence à s'inverser
parce que le patronat n'a jamais accepté
ça tu te doutes qu'être minoritaire dans
la gestion d'un d'un Mago alors à
l'époque c'était pas 800 milliards
d'euros mais c'était déjà conséquent
assurance maladie et cetera l'État n'a
jamais accepté ça et les dirigeants
politiques français qui étaient de
droite l'ont pas plus accepter donc
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils font ce qu'on
appelle le paritarisme à un moment ça
c'est sous Pompidou où ils disent bon
maintenant c'est 50 50 dans la
représentation de la SC de la gestion 50
% patronat 50 %
travailleurs là déjà ça commence à
sentir un peu le rousi pour les
travailleurs parce que 50 50 les patrons
sont plus riches tant qu'ons un c'est
une image hein mais tu coronss le
pourcent qui reste voilà tu gagnes et
tuas la majorité donc déjà c'est pas
bon le le l'équilibre qui était en
faveur du travail a été euh a été
attaqué à ce moment-là et puis ensuite
sous Jupé on nous dit maintenant tous
les ans à l'Assemblée nationale dans les
années 90 donc on va faire des lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale qui
viennent d'être rejeté d'ailleurs en en
commission là je crois que cétait
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire qu'en fait les
représentants de la nation les députés
vont se mettre à discuter de qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire de la sécu sociale
alors
que les cotisations viennent pas pas de
l'État français viennent pas de
l'Assemblée tu vois donc en fait l'état
se met à se dire bon on va mettre des
objectifs longam objectif national des
dépenses d'assurance maladie c'est pas
contraignant mais on met des choses
comme ça sur la gestion de nos hôpitaux
on commence à discuter on les mains tu
vois c'est ça qui est dangereux si on
met les mains à l'Assemblée nationale
sur quelque chose qui ne devrait pour
moi être du ressort et de la compéten
que des travailleurs et des patrons moi
ma préférence va un système en faveur
des travailleurs mais à la limite faut
qu'il a aussi un peu de patronat il a
des cotisations
patronales donc on en est
là 1990 ont fait ça tous les ans
maintenant on se' discutter des lois de
financement de la SQ avec des majorités
qui changent tout ça n'a aucun sens moi
je en terme de stab de vision d'avenir
je préfère laisser ça au syndicats de
travailleurs et au patron pour le coup
ils sont dans des visions un peu plus
longues ils sont honnêtes les syndicats
ouais sur la gestion de la SQ je pense
que oui ouais ils ont une masse d'argent
ils doivent la louer ils doivent la
répartir ça doit fonctionner bien je
préfère laisser ça au syndicat et au
patron plutôt qu'au privé tu as déjà
rencontré le MDF non enfin je les ai vu
j'ai on a fait des auditions on a
discuté et cetera mais si tu veux je
veux pas boire des coups ou prendre des
verres ou avoir des rencontres Amic avec
le M c'est peut-être une erur je te
parle d'avoir des relations de travail
d'échanger des points de vue d'échanger
des visions se mettre d'accord sur un
consensus et avancer ensemble alors ça
on le fait et d'ailleurs je sais pas si
tu as vu mais c'était cette semaine euh
dans notre local de la France insoumise
on a fait une journée de travail
justement avec des représentants du
meddeef sur sur l'état un peu du système
français et cetera donc on le fait
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est un ces trucs en
fait de de d'assumer la confrontation
mais aussi le dialogue pareil quand on
avait fait une un des trucs qu'on avait
fait dans la campagne je crois que
c'était 2017 on avait fait une émission
de 5 he de chiffrage du programme et on
avait invité des gens de BFM Business on
avait en fait des gens qui représentent
le point de vue patronal on n jamais tu
parle de BFM Business ah parce qu'il
représente le point de vue patronal
c'est ton ton point de
vue pour moi c'est la courroie de
transmission ça reste des journalistes
oui bien sûr tu es en train de dire que
le journaliste et la courroie de
transmission bah un journal comme les
écho oui mais il est très sérieux un
journal comme les c'est un journal très
sérieux euh moi ça m'arrive de le lire
pas tous les jours mais ça m'arrive de
le lire quand je vois des trucs
intéressants juste je sais que le
dernier paragraphe ça sera pas un truc
socialiste quoi c'est tout mais c'est
pas grave c'est la cohérence tu sais les
médias ils ont des ils ont des lignes
éditoriales B FM business ne se ne se
cache pas sur sa ligne éditoriale les éc
ne se cachent pas sur sa ligne
éditoriale Le Figaro se cache pas puis
après donc les lignes éditorialtion ne
se cache pas pas du tout non d'ailleurs
je leur en veux un petit peu de pas
aller assez loin méia part tout le monde
a une ligne éditoriale moi je reproche
pas au méia d'ailleurs d'avoir une ligne
éditoriale je leur reproche d'avoir
souvent la même c'est ça qui est un peu
différent bref je je passe là-dessus
parce que je reviens sur la SQ sociale
et et et ce qui se passe comme je t'ai
dit il y avait les trois budgets et
cetera 100 milliards d'euros de TVA
alors pour les collectivité locale je
t'ai pas dit le chiffre mais en gros
l'année dernière c'est
euh globalement 50 milliards 50
milliards c'est qu'aujourd'hui on se
prend la tête là en ce moment on est en
train de dire faut faire 10 milliards de
de coupe absolument et cetera tu prends
1/5è de cette somme le problème est
réglé et je te dis pas que faut tout
arrêter et cetera mais tu vois ce qu'on
a créé en fait c'est un déficite
monstrueux et d'ailleurs la la Cour des
comptes le rappelle dans un dans un
rapport assez récent là la Cour des
comptes elle dit si tu veux attends
faudrait que je te sorte parce que je
l'ai noté la la citation pour pas me
planter voilà donc elle elle est value
la perte de recette à 38,5 milliards
d'euros au total je te lis hein les
pertes de recettes représentent un/4 du
déficit de l'ensemble des
administrations publiques et de l'État
en 2023 rien que sur ça je t'ai même pas
encore parlé de la SC attends ça va
venir les réformes de la fiscalité
locale et du financement de
l'audiovisuel public c'est V qu'on on le
met c'est une somme plus faible c'est
tellement absurde sont à l'origine de la
moitié de la hausse du déficit des
administrations publiques intervenues
entre 2017 et
2023 le déficit public ça vient de là
alors ok après on peut dire on fait un
choix mais moi je demande à ce qu'on
évalue maintenant sur c'est dire ok on a
supprimé la taxe d'habitation à qui ça a
profité est-ce que ça a tant profité que
ça aux classe moyenne un petit peu mais
est-ce que tout le monde a compensé en
le payant au supermarché dans des trucs
tu vois c'est en fait on a pris sur la
consommation des gens on a créé un
système complètement pervers on a dé
déterritorialiser une forme d'impôt on a
fait perdre du pouvoir d'action et des
légitimités même démocratiques derrière
sur des communes des départements et
cetera parce que ton argent vient de
l'État maintenant tu as même plus le
pouvoir de fixer les taux et cetera mais
j'ai communiste
c'est pour ça qu'il faut se méfier de
l'État c'est qu'en fait les capitalistes
ils sont géniaux pour te faire croire
que ils veulent juste ils veulent juste
tu sais quitter la gestion des choses
mais en fait ils prennent le contrôle de
tout et après effectivement ils peuvent
le vendre au privé ils peuvent le filer
au privé mais n'empêche d'abord il y a
cette il y a une espèce de prédation de
l'État et c'est exactement la même chose
qui est en train de se passer pour la
sécurité sociale dans des dans des dans
des proportions plus grandes alors c'est
vrai que la SQ sociale c'est un budget
plus grand mais l'année dernière par
exemple le chiffre de TVA qui a été
transféré à la CQ c'est quand même 60
milliards d'euros tu mets les 50
milliards d'euros des collectivités plus
les 60 milliards d'euros de la CQ de TVA
transférer tu retrouves les 100
milliards qui me manquaient quand je
regardais le budget de l'État en me
disant c'est bizarre on était à 219
milliards d'euros je crois en 2023 et on
a quasiment que 100 milliards qu'on
retrouve dans le budget en fait le
fondement de ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est que le premier impôt du
pays qui est aussi l'impôt le plus
injuste parce que la TVA c'est pas juste
la TVA tu vas au supermarché que tu sois
une classe populaire classe moyenne ou
classes les plus riches tu payes le même
taux sur le même produit donc c'est un
impôt qui est pas juste et en plus quand
tu es une classe populaire en général tu
as pas d'autrre choix que de consommer
quoi voilà survivre ouais tu consommes
tu consommes pour acheter à manger tu
consommes ton paquet de pâes et cetera
quand voilà ça représente une une part
de tes dépenses plus importante que les
plus riches ils achètent aussi les
patttes et cetera mais ils ont plein
d'argent restant pour payer d'autres
trucs derrière donc l'impôt le plus
injuste en fait maintenant il est
utilisé pour ça et dans la CQ c'est la
même chose moi je m'en suis rendu compte
en lisant une loi de règlement un peu un
document un peu technique cararrête les
dépenses et pareil je vois marqué noir
sur blanc en plus hein euh l'affectation
d'une part de la TVA a été faite pour
compenser les exonérations de cotisation
sociale décidé notamment après le cice
et cetera je peux je peux te poser une
question ou pourquoi on a mis milliard
de dett en plus tuas auditionné Bruno Le
Maire il t'a dit ça comment oh Bruno le
il a sauvé l'économie française d'après
lui mais attends attends du
coupellig obstacle et on devait mettre
la Russie à terre aussi non mais il y
avait plein de trucs comme ça ça
commenceis tu vois en parlant de dette
il y a un truc qui qui est super drôle
ça me fait penser parce que je crois que
je l'ai noté en plus mais c'est dans
c'est dans le dernier rapport de la Cour
des comptes que j'avais que j'avais lu
ce qui est très drôle c'est que vu que
cet argent il a été compensé avec
l'argent de la TVA c'est une recette en
moins pour le budget de l'État
mais vu qu'il y a pas eu de baisse de
dépenses significativ à ton avis comment
l'État il a fait pour encaisser ce
transfert ici c'est moi qui pose des
questions mais je réponds la dette bah
il est emprunté variable bah alors là
oui alors là oui parce qu'on a eu tout
un truc sur alors aujourd'hui je sur les
emprunts j'ai pas envie de m'éparpiller
maintenant mais sur les emprunts il y a
il y a il y a plein de choses à dire en
fait je pense que l'erreur sur les
emprunts qu'on a fait sur les OATi les
taux d'émission à taux variable et
cetera c'était plutôt en 2017 201 2019
aujourd'hui peut-être que les taux
variables faut voir parce
queeffectivement vu que les taux sont
haut peut-être qu'ils vont r descendre
mais en 2017 quand les taux ils sont
quasiment à zéro pourquoi tu empruntes
avec des taux variables alors que tes
taux d'emprunt ils sont à quasiment zéro
pourquoi tu fais ça ils nous ont répondu
oui c'est parce qu'on met pas tous les
œufs dans le même panier les œufs les
œufs les œufs voilà on met pas tous les
œufs dans le même panier alors ok on met
pas tous les deux dans le même panier
mais là quand même ça nous coûte un peu
cher d'avoir vraiment mis un œuf dans un
panier qui était pourri on le savait
combien ça vous coûte euh je sais plus
combien on était sur les ordes de
grandeur je crois qu'on était sur au
moins du 15 20 milliards quand j'en
avais discuté en 2022 je voudrais qu'on
fasse une expérience de pensée toi et
moi ouais je voudrais que tu défendes
Bruno le ma Emmanuel Macron pendant 2
minutes il reste une minute
30 mais non mais alors moi je vais le
faire à ta place ok non je vais le faire
je vais le
faire nous avons besoin de soutenir nos
entreprises et pour ça il faut mettre le
paquet dans la compétitivité parce qu'on
vit dans un monde ouvert et dans un
monde féroce vu qu'on n pas naïf si nous
ne faisons rien pour diminuer notre
compétitivité pour pour augmenter notre
compétitivité pour diminuer nos coûts
pour diminuer nos charges et ben les
Chinois et les Américains vont tout nous
piquer il y a une cohérence dans ce
qu'il disent le problème c'est que ils
ont balancé de l'argent n'importe
comment à n'importe qui c'estàdire
producteur de sac comme Louis
Vuitton c'est pas la priorité pour moi
le secteur industriel par exemple ok
quand on diminue la ce qu'on appelle
l'impôt dont je t'ai parlé la cvea
contribution ça a tendance à visit un
peu plus le secteur industriel mais
aujourd'hui on est même pas capable de
faire le bilan de tout ça tu triches il
reste une minute à défendre Bruno ah non
non mais attends non même pas même pas
il y avait 15 secondes je pense pas plus
non mais on est on est on est même pas
capable de faire le bilan de cette
politique là c'està-dire on a balancé
comme ça l'argent et on l'a fait
financer par la consommation populaire
moi c'est çaexlique comment tuexpliques
le monque d'anticipation le manque de
courroit de transmission le manque de
bah où est-ce qu'on va comment tu prends
ça pour la 7e compagnie c'est la 7e
compagnie qui arrose tout le monde
histoire que tout le monde se taise
c'est quoi c'était de la panique il
sortaiit du covid ils étaient un peu
couroussés comme ils font jamais
d'anticipation géopolitique ils étaient
en avec les Russes qui commencent à leur
mettre la pression là ils sont
doublenout parce que les Américains qui
le sont en train de leur faire un petit
enfant dans le dos comment comment
texplique ça là on est en train de se
rendre compte qu'on est vassau des
États-Unis qui assez
marrantopard pour enfin il y en a qui
sont allés saluer Trump et l'applaudir
là j'ai V mour et compagnie enfin moi ça
me fait très rire l'international
fasiste avant Trump il y avait Biden
avant Biden il y avait Trump et avant
Trump il y avait Obama Obama ouais on a
jamais eu d'intérêt commun avec les
Américains sur ça enfin bon je passe
làdessus le Danemark est en train de se
rendre compte de ce que c'est qu'être un
vassal politique mais tu as déjà été au
danemarque non tu devrais mais j'ai
envie d' aller si je suis pas très loin
rber je suis pas très loin je vais y
aller bref à la nage en voiture pas loin
ou en train même je même y aller en
train moi tu sais depuis roubé on est au
centre de l'Europe en fait
euh comment j'explique ça il y a une
idéologie très puissante et et si tu
veux quand tu fais l'enat quand tu fais
les grandes écoles aujourd'hui de
politique c'est ce qu'on t'apprend voilà
on t'apprend qu'en fait on prend des des
choses pour àis par exemple c'est le
marché qui fixe la valeur des choses voà
c'était pas le cas dans les années 60
hein tu sais avant les marchés
financiers c'était même pas dans le PIB
on le comptait même pas là aujourd'hui
c'est le marché qui fixe la valeur donc
faut se conformer au marché aux intérêts
du marché il faut absolument libérer que
l'État soit utilisé pour libérer les
entraves à la compétition et cetera faut
que marché soit libre et non faussé ça
on t'apprend ça en fait he c'est une
idéologie qui continue à à tourner dans
la tête des dirigeants français surtout
européens en fait c'est un c'est c'est
un état d'esprit européens qui fait que
faut pas de barrièrees faut pas de
douane parce qu'on a des mais c'est des
modèles mathématiques hein presque he
pour certains tu vois de d'optimisation
de donc bon ils sortent d'école avec ça
et puis vu qu'en plus ils se fréquentent
tous ils sont tous potes c'est c'est si
tu veux ils sont en relation directe
avec les demandes du grand patronat B ça
c'est gratuit tu as déjà été lesiniltré
ou non mais mais comment tu peux dire
qu'ils se connaissent tous je me fais
non ils se connaissent pas tous ça
serait un juste puis c'est pas un truc
de pourri tu vois mais juste en fait ils
se fréquentent en permanence ils ont les
liens ils ont les contacts ils ont pas
les contact avec les gens de roubé qui
vont faire leur cours au supermarché qui
sont pas contents de ce qui se passe
avec la TVA tu vois c'est pas les
doléances ne viennent pas de là ils
donent de l'importance à des gens dans
des sommets dans le Summit choose France
et cetera tu le vois en fait ouais mais
c'est ça choose France you France et
cetera tous ces trucs en fait le but
c'est d'attirer les gens qu'on estime
être ceux qui ont qui produisent de la
valeur la référence le machin il y a une
cl lecture il y a une clé de lecture à
ça ou c'est simplement genre la kirmess
où on appelle les copains pour récolter
un peu de fric et pour pouvoir briller
sur les plateaux télé non la clé de
lecture c'est fondamentalement
l'idéologie qui les imprègne après ça ça
peut arriver qu'il y a des potes mais tu
vois moi j'annonce pas de trucs sans
avoir d'éléments tangibles il y a eu des
pactes de corruption qui ont été
soulevés par Olivier marlex ou autres
sur Alstom ou autre ça ça ça c'est des
choses qui arrivent mais moi je je si tu
veux ça ne m'amuse pas de déclarer oui
alors ils ont donné de la tune à LVMH je
parce qu'ils sont copins avec Vitton ça
ça c'est pas grave en fait quelque j'en
sais rien je le sais pas par contre ce
que je sais c'est que Bernard Arnaud en
ce moment il met la pression pour pas
que le projet de loi de finance il passe
et il le dit clairement il l'a dit dans
une conférence de presse c'était hier ou
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs je que c'est très
actuel il paye combien d'impôts sur les
sociétés Bernard Arna 2 milliards lui
lui il dit il dit faut pas que ça passe
à 33 je crois c'est c'est un truc comme
ça imp sur les sociétés à l'heure Act
imp sur les société non là on est à 25
on est à 25 on nous dit c'est alors
avant c'était 33 d'ailleurs c'était le
tau normal avant en France c'était
33 faut savoir quand même que même au
stat si tu veux il y a un impôt sur les
sociétés hein c'est pas combien euh
alors ça ça dépend parce que tu as une
base fédérale qui a 21 et après ça
dépend des états j'imagine que Texas
ouais donc j'imagine Queau Texas c'est
moins fort en ce moment New York ça doit
être 7 % tu as déjà été au Texas non
j'ai déà fait New York j'ai fait Chicago
j'ai pas fait le Texas je suis pas
beaucoup allé aux États-Unis pour être
honnête mais c'est un pays assez
fascinant par ailleurs mais donc en fait
après ça dépend des bases des États mais
tu as à plus de 20 % d'impôt sur les
sociétés la France c'est pas un enfer à
25 % c'est pas vrai et à 33 après tout
dépend de ce que tu en fait de ton impôt
sur les sociétés si c'est util si c'est
de l'argent capté par l'État utilisé
pour redistribuer pour booster un
secteur industriel moi je moi je prends
et pour payer les intérêts de la dette
mais les intérêts de la dette donc ce
que je te disais c'est qu'en fait on est
en train nous-même de les creuser avec
nos politiques aujourd'hui c'est ce qui
se passe CQ social je te fais exactement
le même tableau parce que justement je
je je vais te le faire depuis tout à
l'heure mais donc on a fait le cice les
effets sur l'emploi euh si tu veux
courts des comptes et ce nous disent
qu'en fait c'est un montant d'argent par
emploi public enfin d'argent public par
emploi qui qui est délirant euh tout ça
nous coûte 60 milliards d'euros par
exemple l'année l'année dernière de
transfert de TVA vers euh la sécu
sociale d'exonération de cotisation moi
ce que je regrette on peut faire des
exonérations de cotisation à la limite
pourquoi pas pourquoi on peut on peut on
peut discuter avec le patronat de dire
bah tiens tel secteur euh euh on peut
regarder euh comment on vous a comment
vous exénère de cotisation les petites
boîtes par exemple bon ok moi tu vois
roué j'ai c'est vrai les gens qui
montent ne serait-ce que les commerces
alimentaires et
cetera payer les salariés on sait que
c'est compliqué donc il y a des
stratégies de contournement c'est
travail au black et cetera et cetera on
le sait donc on peut focaliser sur ça on
peut focaliser sur une industrie on peut
mais là c'est tout Asie mute
c'est-à-dire que les droits sont ouvert
mais seul ceux qui qui savent se
naviguer dans le labyrinthe des 200
types d'êes publiqu différentes
peuvent le faire en fait c'est les gens
qui vont Salarier en fait quelqu'un à
temps plein pour faire ça qui est bon
sur ça pour capter les aides publiques
et là ça c'est plus du tout un objectif
d' de tu vois de de de comment dire
d'entraîner un secteur et ce c'est juste
que le plus fort se serve quoi en gros
premier arrivé premier servis c'est
comme quand tu ouvre le supermarché tout
le monde arrive en général c'est les
types les plus balaises qui arrivent qui
prennent la nouvelle ps5 et qui se
barrent ou les plus affamés
ouais ou les plus affamés mais ça marche
pas dans dans le monde de l'entreprise
malheureusement les plus affamés moi je
les vois ils ont pas d'aide publiqu hein
même leur expert comptbl ils savent pas
naviguer dans
les dans dans le labyrinthe des aides
publiques il pourraient toucher hein
c'est vrai en soit il pourrait tu es en
train de me dire qu'il y a des gens qui
pourraient bénéficier de choses et qui
demandent pas
par c'est trop compliqué oui mais c'est
un classique en
France tu tu pourrais bénéficier d'aide
publique pour tes entreprises tu
pourrais bénéficier d'aide sociale le
non recours à l'aide sociale et cetera
en fait tout ça est beaucoup plus
important par exemple que la fraude on
parle de milliards d'euros mais l'état
ça l' range quelque part aussi ça
l'arrange sur le non recours aux aides
sociales ça l'arrange parce que ça fait
des rentrées d'argent qui sont moins
fortes enfin des dépenses moins forte
que que ce que ça arrange de maintenir
le truc dans le flou et en plus toutes
les administrations ont leur propre
logique les CAF sont en galère pa emploi
ENF France service et cetera manque de
moyens donc en fait il y a tellement de
pression y compris sur les salariés tu
vois la pression elle tombe d'épaule en
épaule il y a un moment tu vois tu peux
pas courir après les gens pour leur dire
à quel aid ils ont droit voilà c'est
comme ça qui est fait le le système
français et donc sur la SC sociale on
est sur le même système et là on en
revient à ce que je te disais au début
c'est comment l'État met sa main dans le
système de la protection sociale et
quand tu mets 60 milliards d'euros par
an je suis désolé mais tu commences à
avoir quelque chose à dire pour de vrai
c'est c'est je comprends pas le le terme
état c'est pourquoi tu comprends pas
ftionnair c'est ceux qui qui sont
enracinés depuis 25 ans dans leur poste
c'est les les les bons petits soldats du
pouvoir politique c'est qui l'état bah
c'est un peu tout ce que tu as dit
c'est-à-dire c'est c'est la structure
étatique la bureaucratie étatique dans
l'état il y a le bloc communal he parur
il y a les communes et cetera donc tu as
plusieurs strates comme ça
d'organisation de l'État commune
département région état central
ministère direction ministérielle
responsable politique à la tête des
directions ministérielles et tout ça et
comment dire il y a des il y a une
utilité il y a aussi beaucoup de
bureaucratie il y a aussi beaucoup
d'utilité parce que sans agent tu ne
peux rien faire mais il y a beaucoup de
bureaucratie dans certains coins il y a
des administrations qui se cré leur
propre bureaucratie pour avoir leurs
chauffeurs et cetera puis tu en as
d'autres qui font avec les moyens du
bord et qui font bien enfin tu vois je
je il y a pas une vision juste de l'État
en soi mais moi je dis par contre le
mouvement dans lequel on est tu vois la
politique c'est aussi des mouvements
c'est que cet étatl par exemple rentre
dans la gestion de la sécurité sociale
les décideurs politiques ils font un
choix conscient que là ils sont en train
de de de de de mettre le financement de
l'État et de rendre la sécurité sociale
dépendante du financement de l'État
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait à la base
c'était financé par le travail la CQ
c'est ta cotisation sociale ta
cotisation patronnale c'est orienté
autour du travail là on commence à
orienter le financement de la CQ sur la
consommation populaire qu'est-ce que ton
achat de patte a à voir avec la
production de travail en terme de
prospective d'anticipation quand la
consommation se vautre le système de
financement que tu m'as décrit mort tu
es mort mais c'est mort enfin c'est si
tu veux les plats quand quand tu as de
l'inflation aujourd'hui on n'est pas sur
un phénomène où va y avoir de la
déflation c'estàd que les ressources de
l'État ilelles vont rester très hautes
hein c'est quoi la stackflation alors ou
là stackflation c'est quand tu non Disla
moi toi non moi je dis rien donc c'est
quoi la stackflation moi j'étais sur la
déflation non je sais pas te dire la
stackflation je t' pasation la déflation
la stacflation c'est quoi la stacflation
pour moi la stacflation dans la
commission des finances sa mais sa des
Mo je pas le savoir tu je te pay 6000
balles par mois non tu as de l'inflation
St inflation il me semble de mémoire que
c'est quand tu as de l'inflation
c'està-dire quand tu as une augmentation
des prix mais que par contre tu as une
stagnation du revenu national mais je
suis pas sûr de ce que je dis voilà je
pense pas que ça soit ça mais bon ben
dis-le moi je dis rien au moin pour les
gens je dis rien t'inquiète pas on a une
plateforme de fa checking on a des
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux on
a un IRC
je savais que tu m'urais sur un truc bon
non mais c'est pas fini écoute non mais
c'est est-ce que tu as terminé sur
l'écume des choses je dis l'éc c'est pas
ah non c'est pas l'écume je te prend je
te prend là je te parle d'écume des
choses ça veut dire que je veux qu'on
élargisse le prisme de lecture et je
voudrais qu'on passe à la géopolitique
les chicl mondiales les marchés
financiers les bloc je voudrais qu'on
parle un petit peu de cours sur Source
parce que ta petite tambouille de
politicien pour masquer que c'est des
bonnes brê qui déshabille Paul pour
réhabiller Jacques pour faire plaisir à
Jacques pour montrer que Jacques a bien
voté
pour moi c'est de la
tambouille c'est de la tambouille de
politique c'est pour toi ça c'est pour
toi pour moi quoi parce que moi pour moi
quand tu fais financer tout ton système
par la consommation populaire et qu'en
plus maintenant il y en a c'est plus
juste les syndicat d'un côté oou les
communes qui choisissent mais tout en
haut de la pyramide de l'État qu'il y a
quelques personnes qui se mettent à
décider de tout ce qu'on fait dans ce
pays ça me pose un problème démocratique
grave et en plus c'est pas soutenable
parce que c'est pas soutenable parce que
désolé mais consommation populaire si
elle se met à stagner mais que les
besoins ils augmentent tu commences à
avoir des difficultés simplement si elle
se met à stagner le scénario catastrophe
c'est si vraiment il y a un effondrement
de la consommation pour l'instant vu
qu'il y a eu de l'inflation les prix ont
augmenté donc les ressources de TVA
elles vont être quand même très hautes
mais c'est aussi un problème parce qu'en
fait avec cet argent on pourrait faire
des super trucs voilà moi je en fait
quand tu as quand tu as 219 milliards
d'euros de recettes de TVA tu as
largement de quoi boucler ton budget
pour pas qu'il ait de déficit et tu es
même pas obligé de tout enlever
c'estàdire quand je te parle de la
social là on nous prend la tête pour 30
milliards d'euros de déficit moi je te
parle de 60 milliards d'euros de TVA qui
ont été transférés donc enlève juste la
moitié garde l'autre moitié allez fait
plaisir au patronat si tu veux et cetera
30 milliards d'euros on laisse mais si
tu si tu n'enlèves que la moié patronat
des bons patrons qui se sacrifient pour
leurs employés tu as des bons patrons
qui servent pas de salaire pour que la
la boîte me Cho attention mais ceux il
touche pas beaucoup d'argent du cice tu
remarqueras euh
tuis c'est ça le problème c'est que les
bons patrons c'est les meilleurs partent
toujours en premier he tu vois mais donc
voilà moi je dis juste ça je dis après
on peut faire des choix tu sais on peut
même baisser des taux de TVA sur les
produits de première nécessité on a
beaucoup d'argent de la TVA juste une
question il y a plein de choses à faire
on met une parenthèse toi et moi
d'accord donc là me faire une liste
comme en Égypte en Tunisie en Algérie
pays du tier monde les pays de premier
les les besoins de première nécessité de
l'huile des pâtes du sucre tout ce qui
est fait pour bourrer le
ventre tu crois que si la France elle
annonce ça ça note auprès des marchés
financiers des agences de notation de ce
que tu veux elle va faire quoi si tu
donnes les prémisses de on est obligé de
sponsoriser pour éviter les meutes tu
crois que ça passe comment moi je crois
que les marchés financiers ils sont pas
aussi bêtes que ce qu'on pense con bah
ouais ils sont très cohérents sils ont
une cohérence implacable ils veent se
faire des profits des dividendes et
cetera mais si tu veux une politique qui
fait en sorte que les gens consomment
plus parce qu'ils ont plus d'argent et
que donc ils aillent plus au cinéma au
super enfin même au supermarché un peu
plus à la bibliothèque évidemment mais
au stade de foot si tu veux au stade de
foot voir du MMA faire des plaisirs et
cetera B en fait tu as les action de
certains autres produits qui vont
augmenter le c'est bête et méchant le
capitalisme c'est vraiment les marchés
regardent des trucs bêtes et méchants
donc donc je suis pas sûr qu'en fait
gens et surtout enfin on parle des
marchés mais moi j'habite à roubé moi
j'ai 46 % de Tau de pauvreté dans ma
ville moi l'urgence c'est pas les
marchés qu'est-ce t'appelle taux de
pauvreté c'est en dessous de00 moins de
1002 moins 1002 le SMIC est à combien en
France il est à 1003 et quelques et le
le seuil de pauvreté en France est à bah
il est à 100 mais après ça dépend quel
est ton indicateur moi je dis je prends
1002 parce que c'est ce qui se passe
pour
ob moins de 100 donc en fait moi j'ai qu
quiment la moitié des gens de ma ville
qui vivent avec moins de 1200 € par mois
tu vois la situation les marchés je m'en
fous enfin tu c'est pas enfin si
évidemment quand tu es un responsable
politique tu peux pas évacuer d'un d'un
d'un tu peux pas balayer ça d'un d'un
revers de la main mais moi j'ai des gens
qui galèrent à se nourrir voilà et qui
consomme il y a du score but chez toi
ouais il y a eu alors j'ai pas eu de
j'ai des cas déclarés mais moi j'ai tout
en fait j'ai tout c'est la ville la plus
pauvre de France hexagonale alors c'est
une ville magnifique aussi il se passe
plein de trucs j'aime pas le
misérabilisme et cetera grand passé
ouvrier grand passé industriel chez moi
roubé watrolo tourcoin incroyable toutes
les usines sont parties mais tu vois on
a un patrimoine on a plein de choses qui
sont restées le patronat à l'époque
faisait des trucs pas solidarité est
restée hein la solidarité est incroyable
beaucoup de grandes familles les gens
les gens s'entraident mais c'est dur et
par exemple tu vois les le Secours
populaire ou autrees en fait ça devient
de plus en plus dur donc il y a une
augmentation du nombre d'agressions on a
des vols on a des la misère c'est ça en
fait moi moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
résoudre cette situationl voilà et
j'estime pas que et en plus j'attends
pas tout de l'État moi quelque part j'ai
envie de dire par moi je me projette
parce que je suis candidat à la mairie
de roubé et et quand je me projette je
me dis pas que ça me va que une ville
comme roubé soit sous perfusion de
l'argent public parce queeffectivement
l'état donne beaucoup c'est sa
responsabilité il a fait partir les
usines il donne la moitié du budget de
fonctionnement donc tu es sur du 100
million euh et donc ça ça me va pas en
fait comme situation rendez-nous des
pouvoirs par exemple rendez des pouvoirs
localement des pouvoirs de taux rendez
des impôts locaux laisser les élus
décider après bah tu auras des élus de
droite qui font des politiques de droite
dans ce CASL c'est aux gens de se
mobiliser c'est c'est aussi le le la
bataille politique peut reprendre de
plus Bell sur ça aujourd'hui ceux qui
sont en train de se faire dépouiller
c'est les départements les départements
ils sont ils sont dans une situation
extrêmement compliquée or les
départements je le rappelle c'est quand
même le financement de ton collège si tu
as des gamins c'est le RSA c'est ce
genre de politique publique et donc moi
quand je vois le département du Nord ah
oui y a l' social à l'enfance aussi donc
tous les gamins qui sont dans des
situations extrêmement compliquées ces
enfants là qui sont extrêmement mal
accueillis très très mal dans le
département du Nord moi j'ai fait un
courrier je fais un signalement au proc
sur le président du département et
cetera parce que c'est une catastrophe
avec lui mais faut savoir que la moitié
des SDF en France sont des anciens de
l'Aide Sociale à enfance ils sont passés
par l'Aide Sociale à enfance donc tu
vois moi je je vois ces politiques
publiques dont on parle peu les
départements les régions département en
train de me dire que l'aide sociale
le retour si tu peux me permettre de
parler comme ça le retour sur
investissement c'est bah en tout cas les
effets de l'abandon de ça sont
catastrophiques mais parce que
aujourd'hui une journée une soirée
pardon dans un hôtel c'est-à-dire où le
gamin ou la gamine qui va très mal est
entre quatre murs seul sans
professionnel pour aller le voir coûte
moins cher qu'une journée soit dans des
dispositifs d'accueil alors il y a les
familles d'accueil mais aussi des
dispositifs d' il c'est-àdire des
centres d'accueil où il y a des
professionnels qui sont là la nuit qui
gèent les crises de décompensation
c'est-à-dire les crises de panique les
les les tentations auto d'automutilation
voir suicidaire ou voir les passages à
l'acte violent on parle très beaucoup
dans ceux envers les autres qui les
rendent parfois dangereux mais en vrai
les gamins de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
ils font du mal à eux voilà et ça tu
vois c'est l'effet concret aussi de
l'affaiblissement de la place des
départements qui sont en train de se
faire complètement vider à la place on
met des régions grandes régions aucune
cohérence d'ailleurs et nos politiques
publiques sont aussi faites à partir de
moi je pense qu'on a besoin d'une
réforme de l'État en fait vraiment de
comment tout ça s'organise comment tout
ça se finance c'est vraiment un sujet on
en parle pas beaucoup mais
l'organisation de l'État la manière dont
on utilise votre argent quel moment on
l' on l' loue c'est quoi la cohérence de
tout ça juste une parenthèse tu connais
la blockchain un peu ouais c'est
compliqué à flécher est-ce que suivre
chaque euro c'est possible en France
oui mais d'ailleurs Bruno Lemer le dit
on est à l'euro près mais c'est possible
sur des politiques publ que Bruno Lemer
dit ah bah oui parce que c'est pas vrai
sur les aides aux entreprises c'est ça
le truc c'est qu'en fait c'est vrai pour
quand tu dépenses par dans l'éducation
nationale on est capable d'aller gratter
jusqu'au moindre pupitre tu sais ce qui
se passe en ce moment par exemple dans
ma circonscription et un peu partout
dans le Nord et dans les haut de France
c'est que la région a repris sur de
l'argent sur les fonds de roulement des
lycées
que en fait les lycées ont des fonds de
roulement et ça vient prendre des alors
les fonds de roulement c'est fait pour
être sûr que le lycée en gros va voit
son fonctionnement assuré même en cas de
problème donc tu as des fonds de
roulement à 20 jours par exemple qui te
permettent de tenir 20 jours d'autres 30
jours ça dépend de la durée sur lequel
tu veux gérer les moments critiques fond
de roulement bah là ils ont pris des
40000 € des 50000 € dans certains lycées
de
Mirco voilà donc ça on est capable je je
t'assure qu'à l'euro prè on peut on est
capable d'aller voir par contre sur les
les dispositifs des entreprises et
cetera il y a aucun TR aucune
traçabilité après tu peux pas je trouve
c'est une connerie de dire à l'urprè il
y a un moment tu investis tu essayes de
voir les effets de ta politique mais
clairement il y a il y a un contrôle
hyper fort sur les plus pauvres sur les
collectivités et cetera et cetera sur la
CQ mais par contre il y a un relâchement
quand il s'agit d'aide aux entreprises
qui est terrible quand tu es au RSA on
peut regarder ton compte en banque ça
c'est un truc je je ne sais pas si on se
rend compte de de la violence que c'est
nous déjà peut-être que les gens qui
nous écoutent se disent mais est-ce que
tu aimerais que que que que la CAF ou
autre regarde ton compte en banque quoi
que quelqu'un d'autre g regarde ton
compte en banque et donc quand tu es au
RSA on peut ouvrir ton compte en banque
on peut regarder ce que tu fais et si tu
as de l'argent vu que c'est un RSA socle
si tu as 100 € je sais pas pour un
anniversaire de quelqu'un de ta famille
ou autre quelqu'un qui te donne 100 € on
peut déduire ces 100 € de ton RSA tu
vois l'humiliation et tu vois la
capacité qu'elle ét en fait de
surcontrôler nos vies et de surcontrôler
l'attribution de nos dépenses et cetera
sur euh sur sur ce qu'il estime voilà
devoir faire mais par contre en terme
d'aide aux entreprises il y a plus
personne moi c'est ça que j'aime pas
contrôler un minimum les entreprises oui
mais pareil
l'URSAF en fait bon les services des
impôts par exemple service des impôts
c'est un des services les plus
performants en France là pour le coup ça
ça fonctionne globalement assez bien
malgré quelques bugs mais mais si tu
veux oui on va contrôler les petites
entreprises oui on va chercher la petite
bête après c'est vrai qu'il y a aussi
des fraudes notamment à la TVA ou aut
sur les entreprises et des fois l'étaat
est plus sympa que ce qu'on pense mais
mais par contre les grandes boîtes les
grandes sommes les grands mouvements de
sommes qui sont engagé sur les grandes
boîtes non c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai
ils ont du courage d'ailleurs ceux qui
contrôlent oui bien sûr parce qu'ils
font agressés et cetera enfin je non
mais ils sont surtout surtout super serv
fil des
conseils on a une vision de alors c'est
vrai que des fois tu peux tomber sur
quelén ouais ouais je suis d'accord avec
toi c'est un truc qu'on dit pas assez
c'est que bon c'est vrai que quand tu es
petit patron tu as pas envie de te faire
contrôler et quelque part bon tu as
acheté une caisse de vin tu as des
usages un peu mixtes entre soit c'est
pour la boîte mais des fois tu le
ramènes chez toi parce pas normal
normalement l'ext il do texliquer voilà
c'est ça c'est pas normal mais les
impôts sont plutôt facilitateurs en vrai
en vrai bon des fois des fois ils font
un redressement ça arrive he mais moi ce
que je regrette c'est que les gens
soient pas au courant tu vois moi roué
quel est le service qui va aider les
petits jeunes qui font qui font des
trucs de restauration à bien tout faire
clean en fait c'est des gens qui sont en
demande he les entrepreneurs aujourd'hui
ils sont demande d'aide ils sont mais il
y a tellement de paperas pour toucher
les aides et cetera que c'est bon
tuabandonnes tu vois c'est bon tu donc
moi c'est ça et c'est ce contrôle là qui
se retrouve jusque dans nos vies après
tu le vois dans dans la société de
contrôle qu'on est en train de mettre en
place qui là est encore plus mais mais
ça se rejoint et moi ce que ce que je te
dis ça parce que pendant le le le les
dans les débats qu'on a aujourd'hui la
question c'est comment tu rapproches les
gens dans une France qui est en train de
qui est en train de se séparer en trois
bloc où effectivement tu as des
populations entières qui se parlent plus
qui veulent plus se voir et cetera où tu
orientes ta colère et moi c'est pas
juste le capitalisme c'est aussi l'état
ton problème c'està-dire les dirigeants
politiques qui sont responsables de cet
étatl tu peux canalyser ta colère là moi
je pense que c'est ça ce qui comment tu
expliques la défiance de la défiance de
quoi des citoyens ens du peuple du
peuple face à la classe
politique par
l'expérience l'expérience c'està-dire
qu'en fait les gens sont au courant en
fait c'est pas qu'ils sont au courant
d'un point de vue érudit et cetera mais
juste ils sentent bien qu'il y a un
souci c'est-à-dire en fait moi quand je
dis il y a 219 milliards d'euros
d'argent récolté de la TVA les gens
n'ont pas forcément accès à ces chiffres
mais enfin quand même les infos elles
circulent maintenant avec les réseaux
sociaux et cetera combien de zé 1
milliard combien combien de zé 1
milliard bah 1000 1 2 3 4 pour 1000
10000 attends 4 10000 100000 1 million
100 millions 100 millions
je suis à 9 là c'est ça oua non mais
je c'est plus efficace en général les
vieilles dans les viuxux fait les
meilleurs ouis ou les meilleures Saces
juste juste un détail on va passer à
l'international est-ce que tu veux
rajouter un sujet local non mais juste
sur le local parce que vu qu'on parle on
parle à
l'international je vais faire la
transition moiême c'est en fait au fond
par rapport à ce qui se passe à
international quel est le modèle moi ce
qui m'intéresse aussi c'est de
poétiquement me dire quel est le modèle
que l'on propose à notre peuple et au
peuple du monde pour les convaincre de
rejoindre un com pas une alliance pas
mais pour les convaincre d'être entraîné
dans un même mouvement tu vois et les
États-Unis ils ont leur modèle c'est
l'individu et roi tout le monde se
démerde celui qui gagne c'est le
meilleur tu vois musk machin bon on
cache qu'il y a des êtres publicques et
cetera aussi mais voilà l'individu est
roi BL chinois c'est la société donc là
il y a plus d'individus c'est la société
l'individu n'existe pas et tu es au
service tout tout le monde doit être au
service de la société nous en Europe on
a inventé un modèle que je trouve assez
passionnant qui est celui du citoyen
éclairé en fait qui qui qui éclairé par
qui éclairé par sa conscience qui est
permise par après ça c'est la République
sociale par par l'éducation par en fait
le fait de devenir quelqu'un de meilleur
globalement dans la philosophie c'est ça
c'est tu deviens meilleur l'homme est
perfectible dirait ta pierre ouais tu tu
es l'être humain est perfectible c'est
Rousseau c'est Jean-Jacques Rousseau
c'est on peut devenir meilleur et et on
peut élever le niveau de la société
élever son niveau de conscience de
l'autre et cetera quand quand quand le
camp adverse dit il y a un ivellement
par le
bas ça dépend de quoi il parle la
société par exemple on arrive de moins
en moins à faire société c'est une
réalité mais par contre le niveau
d'éducation et cetera n'est pas nivelé
totalement par le bas c'est pas vrai
quand tu compares moi à roubé fut un
temps où les gens étaient à l'usine il
galéraient il trimaient pendant des des
tu vois des journées entières de travail
ils étaient exposés à des substances
chimiques il rentraient chez eux ils
étaient crevés ils étaient plus en
capacité de faire grand-chose dodo
alcool des fois souvent et cetera et
donc c'était c'était une situation ouais
c'était beaucoup plus compliqué leur
gamin aujourd'hui ont fait des études
ont des trajectoires sociales
ascendantes donc donc le niveau scolaire
par exemple s pas effondré nous on a
l'impression parce que c'est vrai que
sur les apprentissages fondamentaux on a
des problèmes les vrais problèmes qu'on
a par exemple en terme d'apprentissage
c'est on sait plus que on sait plus
vraiment créer des générations
d'ingénieurs et cetera c'est plus ça qui
m'inquiète et même nos chercheurs sont
précarisés donc bon tu es sur un système
comme ça mais j'en reviens à ça parce
que ce que je te dis en fait sur ce
qu'on fait de nos ressources et sur la
manière dont l'État prend le contrôle de
nos vie on est vraiment en train de
proposer le pire modèle c'est-à-dire on
est influencé par les States concrè en
fait faut que l'individu faut que le
marché faut faut qu'il ait plus rien en
fait faut que tout s'autorégule tout le
monde se démerde mais d'un autre côté on
a quand même un système où l'État hyper
en contrôle à la au début des
populations les plus
précaires avec en plus une histoire
coloniale qui fait que les populations
des quartiers sont c'est c'est quelque
chose d'autre mais qui qui se voit en
fait sur toutes les populations les plus
précaires et les moyennes c'està-dire
qu'en fait je sais pas si tu as remarqué
augmentation de pathologie ancienne oui
bah alors oui tu as ça alors moi par
exemple un des plus gros problèmes dans
ma circonscription c'est tout tout bête
he mais c'est les pathologies mentales
euh donc
schizophrénie
bipolarité ça faut savoir que j'ai un
hôpital psychiatrique la pédopsychiatrie
j'ai h postes de médecin ouverts zéro
médecin ouais et en psychiatrie adulte
là je crois qu'il nous reste un médecin
et demi ils sont tous en train de partir
alors ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas de
médecin en fait c'est les médecins de la
métropole qui viennent de faire ce qu'on
appelle de la coordination donc ils
arrivent ils lisent les dossiers ils
font la prescription parce que tu sais
sans médecin tu peux pas prescrire les
aides soignantes peuent pas prescrire
des médicaments faut qu'il y a un
médecin les infirmières peut-être un
jour les infirmières peut-être un jour
mais bon l'idéal c'est quand même que ça
soit des médecins c'est vrai que nous on
s'acommode un fonctionnement qui est pas
sain au médecin ah tu fais comment en
fait c'est en fait c'est les aides
soignantes et les infirmiers et les
infirmières qui préparent les dossiers
en vérité parce que les médecins ne
voient pas les malades c'est ça le
problème donc moi nous on a ça tu vois
bon après j'ai l'obésité j'ai le diabète
diabète très très dur chez moi et du
coup tu perds des générations de gens
qui ne peuvent plus travailler par
exemple à partir de 40 ans en fait quand
tu as un diabète de type 2 ou même plus
voilà tu en fait tu vois ces politiques
publiqu là où l'absence de politique
publique elle crée des dégâts même d'un
point de vue complètement tu vois
travail travail travail elle crée des
dégâts sur le marché du travail en fait
donc bon ça c'est encore autre chose
mais quand je te disais ce modèle là
voilà on épouse le pire du pire
c'est-à-dire à la fois une société
complètement atomisée d'individus mais
de l'autre un hyper contrôle de l'État
sur les classes les plus plus précaires
et je voulais te donner un exemple moi
ça m'avait assez ça m'avait frappé je
sais pas si tu as remarqué mais quand il
y a des mobilisations de gilets jaunes
ou de ou ou d'agriculteurs ou autre et
qui se retrouent face à des CRS je sais
pas si tu as remarqué c'est déjà arrivé
plusieurs fois directement c'est des
populations qui n'ont tellement pas
l'habitude en fait parce qu'ell
n'étaient pas au courant qu'elles
étaient contrôlées et réprimé ils disent
mais pourquoi vous allez pas dans les
quartiers tu vois pourquoi vous emprenez
pas au au noir et aux Arabes en gros moi
moi je suis un honnête citoyen tu vois
il y a un truc mais je te rassure il av
des noirs et des Arabes chez G jaunes
ouais je sais mais c'est des réactions
qui arriveculur aussi he je sais mais
c'est des réactions qui prouvent un truc
c'est que et moi c'est ce que j'essaie
de prouver c'est que en fait d'où que tu
viennes à partir du moment où tu
t'opposes à ça tu vas te faire monter en
l'air quoi en gros c'est l'état fera pas
de cadeau c'est pas vrai tout ce qui t'a
fait croire parce qu'on a mis une
mentalité très coloniale et cetera de
quelque part tu seras jamais au fond du
panier comme les autres tu vois comme ce
dans les quartiers tu seras jamais en
fait pas vrai parce que le consensus il
a été rompu en France on a vécu pendant
des années avec quelque part une forme
de contrat un peu tacite de de quand à
quand 30ente glorieus après ouais un peu
après 30ente glorieus où on a dit même
même à l'époque où la France était un
empire colonial il y avait des classes
laborieuses blanches tu vois français de
Souge comme on a comme les autres disent
et cetera ça existait qui trimait c'est
qui les autres qui trimaent bah qui
est-ce qui dit les Français de souche
bah moi pour moi c'est l'extrême droite
parce que moi je connais pas le concept
de Français de souche ça me dis rien je
sais pas ce que c'est moi je guirot
c'est du visigo mon nom de famille c'est
du visigo c'était une forme de GR
remplacement très brutal ce qui s'est
passé tu vois c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
c'était peu plat de guerrière qui sont
arrivés
qui ouais et qui ont tellement pété la
gueule au romain qu'on a changé de
d'époque en terme d'histoire quand ils
ont fait le sac de Rome enfin tu vois
donc bon à Laar et compagnie donc en
fait je je sais pas moi ce que ça veut
dire Français de souche il y a des
peuples manique bon bref je passe
là-dessus si tu veux on peut prendre un
autre concept c'est viendra après ouais
là on est à
1h00 43 secondes
on va passer à un autre sujet ouais euh
quelle est ta clé de
lecture qui quel on va dire comment te
formuler
ça quel est ton laser ta clé de lecture
pour comprendre ce qui est en train de
se passer sur
quoi tu peux t'appuyer pour comprendre
ce qui se passe à l'heure actuelle
à l'échelle internationale et sur le
développement des 5 10 15 20 prochaines
années ok
euh bon déjà il y a un truc qu'il faut
assumer c'est qu'il y a une incertitude
là je je pense qu'il y a pas beaucoup
d'analyses si tu veux qui peuvent qui
peuvent te dire avec précision ce qui va
se passer euh faut l'accepter cette
incertitude attends redis-moi ce que tu
viens de me dire il y a il y a un niveau
d'incertitude politique et géopolitique
je pense qu'il y a peu de gens qui pe à
faire de l'in qu est ta clé de lecture
non non j'en ai pas rien à faire parce
que je vais te parler après de comment
je vois les choses mais mais si tu veux
tu tu dois commencer par le dire
vraiment non mais arrête de comparer au
dernier de la classe non non c'est pas
ça arrête de te comparer à des salles de
de prospective à des salles de crise qui
n'ont jamais rien vu émerger qui n'ont
jamais rien anticipé mais toi tu l'avais
vu émerger liya chinoise liya chinoise
on l'a vu émerger forcément à force de
cracher la gueule des Chinois les
Chinois Ilou ce que je veux te dire
c'est que pendant tu as lu szu ouais
j'ai adoré tu l'as appris par cœur non
je l'ai pas pris par cœur mais j'ai
adoré
faut choisir le terrain quel quel type
de terrain des neuf terrains de guerre
quel terrain là là oui ah là c'est la
Pline ouverte là on est en terrain de
mort ah c'est pleine on est sur la plain
tu sais ce que c'est le terrain de mort
selon Sunzu non je me souviens plus de
ça partout où tu poses ton regard tu te
retrouves encerclé et aller au combat le
plus vite sera le mieux que tu perdes
que tu gagnes on est dans quel terrain
là non pour moi on est sur une plaine où
tout le monde regarde tu vois d'accord
quelle est ta clé de lecture alors j'y
viens moi ma clé de lecture si tu veux
c'est que je vois les deux blocs se
constituer euh géopolitiquement je vois
des alors il y a des blocs qui
s'effondent mais je vois les deux blocs
je vois la surproduction
chinoise je vois l'impérialisme
américain qui là maintenant assume la
force brute je veux dire ils ont
toujours assumé la force brute mais là
vis-à-vis de ses propres vassau
vis-à-vis de l'Europe en fait je vois
qu'on va se faire mais
massacré voilà là je c'est si tu veux le
le truc du Groenland on a tendance à
l'oublier mais c'est le Danemark c'est
quand même un pays européen quoi tu vois
euh et personne ne fait rien personne ne
bouge personne ne dit rien l'Allemagne
risque de tomber avant la France je ne
le pensais pas il y a quelques années
pour être honnête l'Allemagne je
travailleis peut-être pas dans la
géopolitique ouais tu as raison mais
mais bon voilà moi je j'ai pas la
science infuse mais mais si tu veux je
pense que ce que je ce que je peux
penser en terme de ça je pense que dans
l'opinion publique c'est assez commun
tuouvres un média aujourd'hui Touvre les
gens comprennent Queen gros l'Allemagne
a encore une puissance industrielle et
donc elle tient mieux et ben ça c'est en
train de s'effondrer pourquoi sur
production chinoise on fait le Mercosur
on est obligé de faire des traités là
aujourd'hui du style le Mercosur
d'ailleurs qui est pas sûr de passer
mais là tu es en
train s même de ta clé de lecture
pourquoi l'Allemagne se vautre mais
parce queelle est sur une industrie
automobile qui qui fait pas qui a trop
de concurrence contre
elle ça ça c'est encore l'écume des
choses pourquoi l'Allemagne se vutre bah
dis-le-moi parce que je te dis rien je
te POS je veux savoir en fait ta clé de
lecture quel quel est le le
le comment tu visualises l'économie
l'économie c'est quoi la la la monnaie
c'est quoi l'industrie c'est quoi ta
bière c'est quoi le bonbon qui a sur la
table c'est quoi c'est des calories h on
est d'accord ouais pourquoi l'Allemagne
sa vôre société hyper spécialisée
dépendant énergie ultra pas cher ils
sont fait [__] en l' par par les les
Russes et pardonnez-moi de mon Tron
vulgaire ils étaient très contents
d'avoir l'énergie pas cher les Russes
étaient très contents d'avoir un P en
Allemagne et ça ça marchait bien ça
marchait bien bon nstam est tombé les
sanctions sont tombées donc ce que je
voulais entendre c'est quel est le
résumé de ta de ta clé de lecture si ta
clé de lecture c'est Pierre Paul Jacques
il font du business de machin non non
mais quand tu me dis éconie ouais non
mais quand tu me dis économie
surspécialisée je c'est ce que je te
disais sur l'automobile allemande ou non
ouais enfin le si tu veux mon av la clé
de lecture c'est ça c'est pas l'énergie
non c'est pas l'énergie je suis pas très
bon en énergie pour ouais je sais je
sais mais c'est tu sais c technique je
pense que la classe politique est pas
très bonne en général sur ça arrête de
comparer au der non mais t'inquiète non
mais moi ma clé de lecture si tu veux
enfin je je comprends pas très bien ta
question pour être je vais je vais
reformuler ma question pour que tu la
comprennes
mieux qu'est-ce qui mène le monde mis à
part le sexe les armes l'alcool ce que
tu ok le pétrole merci voilà on est
content voilà c'est le pétrole les
veines c'est le pétrole l'énergie le gaz
P oui d'accord ok ok je comprends où tu
veux venir le bois ok ouais je comprends
où tu veux en venir donc là tu me dis
que la classe politique elle est à
milieu de ça ouais ça me fait peur bah
tu as raison d'avoir peur c'est pour ça
qu'il comprennent rien en géopolitique
là en ce moment c'est pour ça qu'il
court comme des poulets sans tête c'est
pour ça que Bruno le mer qui dit on va
te mettre on va mettre on va mettre la
Russie à terre c'était une erreur
manifeste alors après il y a des
conseillés qui ont des bons niveaux en
France hein bon ouais il peut y en avoir
quand même mais ils sont pas écoutés
forcément ils sont pas forcément sont
pas écouté mais parce que regarde Bruno
Le Maire et en fait regarde aujourd'hui
comment se fait la carrière d'un
politique à 30 ans tu es déjà ministre
en tu vois c'est des trucs moi je j'ai
un petit côté Old School mais il y a des
trucs que je vois Gabriel Atal tu vois
des carrières politiques qui se
propulsent comme ça du jour au lendemain
parce que sur les réseaux ça va beaucoup
plus vite et que tu as plus le cursus
honorum qui avait des limites hein tu
vois maire président de département
région ministre machin Alexandre le
Grand quand il a pris la pers il avait
quel âge euh 23
non je je suis pas sûr 23 non on ceouis
il avait la vingtaine enfin après
c'était pas la même le même rapport à la
majorité mais bref non mais tu as raison
donc il y a le pétrole ok
pétrole là je ça veux rien dire si si ça
veut dire des chose si si si si si si on
revient sur le pétrole euh je un peu old
school mais tant pis pétrole
énergie là par exemple on a des choses
que fait la France avec le Maroc sur le
Sahara occidental où on a des projet
hydrocarbure mais je sais pas trop où
ils vont mener mais on a quand même 10
milliards d'euros qui ont été signés ça
c'est quelque chose tu vois la France je
ne sais pas
exactement ce qu'on fait là et donc
notre seul aujourd'hui la seule boussole
des Français c'est de se dire qu'on va
acheter des hydrocarbures américaine
quoi voilà ça c'est notre projet
industriel par exemple c'est bon bah
l'électricité c'est cher on va acheter
des hydrocarbures aux États-Unis sauf
que l'Allemagne tu as raison est
complètement liée à la Russie donc c'est
très compliqué pour elle de débrancher
mais en même temps l'Allemagne est aussi
une annexe des États-Unis aujourd'hui
concrètement quand tu vois comment ça se
passe dans l'Union européenne et cetera
c'est le point de vue autant autant
autant h 24 et nous la France moi ce que
je regrette en fait c'est que nous on a
des partenariats et une présence dans le
monde qui en train de s'effondrer
s'effondrer en Afrique notamment alors
qu'on peut faire des choses bien avec
par exemple l'Algérie en ce moment là
Algérie l'Algérie notre si tu veux on
leur vendait énormément de blé parce
qu'on parle beaucoup de l'énergie il y a
aussi les denré alimentaires c'est les
Russes on leur vendait du blé notre
production elle a été divisée par 3 en 6
ans enfin notre vente de blé à l'Algérie
divisé par 3 en 6ant on peut se dire
c'est pas grave on va trouver d'autres
acheteurs enfin sur des sur des sur des
montants comme ça c'est pas si facile de
trouver des acheteur euh l'Algérie a des
hydrocarbures on a une on a Michelin ils
ont plus trop d'hydrocarbures les
Algériens euh ils en ont encore un peu
hein
euh ils ont une énorme naap fréatique et
cetera enfin moi je je je regarderai
mieux que ça en termeour mieux que ça
aussi he non mais en terme de ressources
en eau et cetera je je t'assure qu'ils
ont des choses éventuellement qu'on peut
nous proposer he parce que la gestion de
l'eau ça va être un sujet on a une usine
Michelin qui ça y est Michelin s'en va
enfin on a pas d'usine Michelin on a
Michelin qui s'en va d'Algérie on a une
usine Renault qui est en panne c'estd on
parle d'automobile qui est quand même un
des secteurs qu'on le veille ou non les
plus importants de l'industrie qui
produisait quand même
60000 60000 voitures par an il y a
quelques années qui à l'arrêt
aujourd'hui donc ça si tu veux c'est un
sujet de préoccupation je te parle d'une
coopération parmi d'autres je te dis pas
qu'il faut tout miser sur l'Algérie mais
là les tensions qu'on mène avec
l'Algérie sur des polémiques
franchement sur les accords de 68 qui
sont même pas favorables aux Algériens
et cetera avec un ministre comme
retaillo qu'en rajoute qu'en rajoute il
se tape la honte parce qu'on a il a
voulu virer un tiktokeur trop tôt même
la justice française maintenant être en
train de le percutter ça ne vaut pas le
coup dit le tiktokur je sais plus faut
je je vais décapiter des trucs des trucs
qui des trucs
scandaleux il a raison mais le mec
devait passer en jugement il devait
passer en jugement en France on le vir
avant c'est une erreur judiciaire de
base de base je dire on fait du droit
même l'Algérie a répondu en droit puis
fa c'est pas un envoyé de l'Algérie le
mec tu vois bien que il fait pas honneur
au au pays algérien donc je vois pas
pourquoi on se met dans la roue comme ça
de ministre qui crée des problèm
économique là on est l'Algérie a pas
voulu récupérer ils ont dit vous regardz
mais non mais c'est pas la Foire du Trô
non plus je veux dire mais non mais tu
arrives avec un avion tu balances un mec
qui est censé avoir un jugement c'est
pas comme ça que ça marche les relations
quand tu es Trump ça peut le faire
éventuellement parce que tu as une
puissance impériale mais il faut arrêter
de penser que la France est une
puissance impériale Raymond hararon
c'était pendant mes études ça c'était il
y a longtemps disais sur les puissances
impériales je sais plus je sais plus
revenons à l'Algérie revenons à
l'énergie tu lecture pourquoi vasy
continue paralgérie on perd des
positions en Afrique subsaharienne là je
sais pas comment Macron a fait pour
dealer avec
kagam donc le Rwanda alors que que la
République enfin en fait le Congo
pourrait on pourrait échanger tu vois tu
pourrais avoir un Piétat de terre en
fait au Congo en terme de partenariat et
cetera là on s'est mis dans les mains de
Kagamé du Rwanda enfin tu vois le genre
d'erreur fondamentale quand même parce
que après c'est ta présence sur le
territoire congolais qui est en question
on on on se fait attaquer des ambassades
et cetera en ce moment donc ça c'est le
genre d'erreur géopolitique je pense que
la France est en train de tourner
complètement le dos à la possibilité si
tu veux de de d'avoir des partenariats
des ressources des échanges avec des
pays qui pourraient être non alignés
avec nous globalement voilà qui serait
moins dans le jeu des empires qu'il
serait encore je parlais de l'Algérie
l'Algérie s'entend aussi bien avec les
États-Unis qu'avec la Chine mais qu'
Serussi d'ailleurs oui bien sûr bien sûr
euh donc donc on se prive de tout Liban
voilà bon Liban c'est pas les ressources
les plus énormes mais en fait tu as
quand même à chaque fois tu as des
sujets d'agriculture oui tu as des en
fait à chaque fois tu as des choses
chaque fois tu as tu as un peu de
ressources parci et nous on est
incapable de faire ça donc là on a une
Union européenne qui se dit bon bah gaz
de chiste américain allez c'est parti et
moi je sais pas honnêtement je je je je
te l'admets là je ne sais pas où on va
si ce n'est qu'on est en train de se
mettre dans la main de puissance qui ne
pense qu'à une chose c'est à nous
dépesser quoi les Américains ça y est
c'est parti en fait c'est c'est parti je
ne sais pas ce que ça va faire il a un
truc qui qui me fait rire c'est l'idée
que j'ai eu beaucoup de médias sur
l'international fasciste mais en fait tu
sais voyez Zemour on va voir Trump Elon
Musk melony et cetera en fait tous ces
gens dans quelques années si tu ve mon
avis ils n'ont pas du tout les mêmes
intérêts nationaux pas du tout les
intérêts nationaux des États-Unis ne
sont pas du tout ceux de la France les
intérêts des États-Unis ne sont pas du
tout ceux du Danemark ni de ceux de
l'Italie ni de ceux de l'Allemagne donc
en fait l'international fasciste elle va
refaire comme elle avait fait en 14 18
si tu veux c'est ça va monter puis après
tu sais pas où ça mène tu sais pas où ça
mène c'està dire la guerre le la guerre
commerciale puis la guerre politique et
si les ressources se rarifient sur cette
dynamique qu'est-ce qui se
passe ça dépend de quel ressources tu me
parles par exemple aujourd'hui en terme
d'agriculture on a des petits
soucis on a des soucis dû à la météo un
peu erratique on va dire surtout au prix
des engrais he ouais ouais on a des gros
gros problèmes puis la gestion de l'eau
va poser un problème parce que c'est
très demandeur en eau et on a tendance à
oublier quand même que la ressource eau
reste le truc fondamental quoi donc on a
encore on a encore des des richesses en
franceç qu'est-ce qui se passe quand il
n'y a plus de foin dans les ateliers et
ben tes métropole elles doivent avoir
une durée d'autoapprovisionnement de je
sais pas de 20 jours 30 jours s n'y a
plus de fois dans les atelierers les
chevaux se battent donc quand tu as
comme si je reprends ton prisme de
lecture une Internationale fasciste qui
se se ils vont se tirer la gueule entre
eux bien sûr c'est ce qu'on mais tu
sais ça a toujours été ça l'analyse de
la mon le fait que le Groenland soit
réclamé par les États-Unis ou Panama ou
le passage du Grand Nord moi je pense
que c'est le passage Grand Nord ou ou
c'est les passages à mon avis qui
intéressent les États-Unis plus à mon
avis mais je connais pas très bien le le
le Groenland mais de ce que je comprends
c'est les voies de passage et quelques
ressources éventuellement dans marins
mais ouais qu'est-ce qu'on fait du
graffite tu fais euh tu fais des
composants comment tuanalyse la
politique du kéoret comment tu analyses
la politique de Macron mis à part
l'interet on va passer sur l'Afrique
parce que c'est euh ouais c'est pour moi
c'est le plus important l'Afrique he
ouais mais c'est massacré là
ouais on a plus de contact en Afrique
que ked danscé tous réunis dir on a plus
de contact pour aider la France et aider
l'Afrique que le Koré réuni donc comment
tu analyses c'est gens là le kedoré
ouais c'est une bonne cantine tu vois je
me suis retrouvé avec un diplomate qui
avait bossé pendant des années et des
années au kéoré
et on
discutait je je tabassais le Kor et là
le Diplômate en face de moi il me dit ah
ouais tuas tu as raison et puis je lu
dis mais pourquoi tu es resté si
longtemps chez
eux ça c'est la question de conscience
qui doivent se poser mais si tu veux
aujourd'hui le Kor le truc de base c'est
qu'il est défaillant voilà pourquoi il
est défaillant parce que moi de ce que
j'analyse c'est que tu as une diminution
des budgets sur toutes nos réseaux
d'ambassade donc je pense que tu ne peux
plus appréhender la réalité de la même
manière quand tu as moins de gens
présents dans le monde avec les moyens
de bien faire leur boulot ça c'est la
règle pour moi de base et ensuite
si si moi je je je crois vraiment que
c'est une règle de base connais les
soirées de l'ambassadeur non tu sais
Suard
ouais ouais bon ok oui tu as raison on
peut faire des on peut faire des
réductions de dépenses mais mais quelque
part je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
tu as vu il il y a une démission là
justement sur l'Algérie du conseiller de
de Macron diplomatique et cetera et et
je pense qu'il naav vu il y a plus
aucune ligne directrice donnée par les
politiques il y a plus rien en fait je
te dis on est en train de se
complètement se détourner de de du du
sens profond de ce qui est en train de
se passer les dirigeants français ne
veulent pas comprendre et alors du coup
ils sont sûrement influencés par les
diplomates moi je les connais pas
personnellement j'ai pas énormément de
lien avec les diplomates mais pour
comment ça se
fait j'ai 32 ans si tu veux je je suis
député depuis 3 ans tu as pas le temps
de t'intéresser à autre chose que le
score but dans ta région bah déjà ça me
prend du temps je te non mais je te le
concède je te le concède moi je je sais
je je suis beaucoup sur mon terrain j'ai
une vision du député très local donc
mais non non je je je sais pas quel est
leur état d'esprit mais quelque part si
tu veux en fait la diplomatie française
aujourd'hui elle s'est fait boouter hors
d'Afrique mais vraiment comme Haïti tu
vois coup de pied au cul dans plusieurs
pays quand même euh et et et il y a plus
de relais il y a plus rien moi quand je
suis allé quand j'étais allé à Tunis en
fait ce qui est dommage c'est que
d'ailleurs les peuples là-bas aiment
bien la France he vraiment et les élites
africaines par exemple ont une certaine
estime de l'idée de la France et de ce
qu'elle a pu porter quand je suis allé à
Tunis on avait des problèmes parce
que il y avait des tags sur un consulat
palestinien puis ils sont arrivés ils
ont nettoyé puis alors tu reviens le
lendemain tu as 36000 tags les trucs
antifance et antiacron beaucoup anti
Macron beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
que ce qu'on pense je pense c'est c'est
quand quand on écoute ça on dit tout le
temps bah c'est les Russes qui sont
derrière ou les Chinois qui sont
derrière non ils en ont marre les
Algériens ils veulent juste qu'on les
respecte il y a pas des gens qui les
titillent un petit peu un peu toujours
enfin ça c'est le jeu des relation
internationales mais mais mais mais les
Algériens demandent juste à ce qu'on les
respecte par exemple tboun il arrive au
pouvoir il dit je ne demande pas
d'argent je veux qu'on me respecte c'est
juste ça là aujourd'hui tu vois ce que
font les ministres remettre en cause les
accords de 68 et ce on est quand même
très loin par exemple de la déclaration
de shirac et de boutflica on est très
loin on en fait tu as quand même réussi
à détourner le sujet je te le conète tu
es un bon politicien on en fait quoi
alors je rebondis sur ton détournement
on en fait quoi des ocutf des UTF ouais
des mecs qui foutent le bordel en France
qui se baladent avec des couteaux qui
s'amusent à chlacer les mecs dans le
métro des mecs qui qui font n'importe
quoi on en fait quoi ok je te réponds
sur les qtf ouais tu sais moi ou j'ai
j'ai j'ai une population qui a une
histoire de l'immigration c'està dire
qu'en fait beaucoup d'Algériens des
arquis aussi hein 10000 arquis dans ma
ville
euh les gens sont venus pour bosser dans
les usines on les a amené là déjà dans
des conditions lamentables d'ailleurs
lamentables dans les courés et cetera
donc ils sont pas là par hasard si tu
veux il faut dire que c'était un peu
lamentable chez eux aussi non euh il y
en a qui ont dû partir de manière forcée
pour les arquis et pour enfin ils ont
été dans des camps hein si tu veux hein
c'est-à-dire ils arrivent dans le sud de
la France ils sont dans des camps et on
leur dit tiens il y a une boîte une
entreprise qui recrute et donc nous à
l'époque c'était la linière et compagnie
donc c'était le textile et en fait c'est
des gens qui ont sacrifié leur santé et
leur vie pour habiller l'Europe tu vois
c'est quand même pas rien non mais pour
nourrir leurs enfants éduquer leurs
enfants oui mais mais je veux dire
l'effet sur le pays ça a été ça aussi tu
vois ils ont ils ont ils ont contribué à
notre grandeur donc il y a un moment et
ces gens-là qui aujourd'hui pour
certains ont 70 ans bon les usines elles
sont parties dans les années 70 donc
c'est quand même des vieilles
générations donc c'est plus leurs
enfants dont on parle il y en a qui ont
encore des occutés
tu vois moi j'ai des grand-mères de 65
ans 70 ans qui ont des octf justement
parce que tu as les accords de 68 qui
ont été faits qui font que tu dois
renouveler à chaque fois pour les
Algériens notamment ton ton laisser
passer enfin ton visa et cetera je suis
désolé mais tu vois moi ça me ça me et
je me dis mais mais quelle était ma
question qu'est-ce qu'on fait par destf
qui foutent le bordel de ta grand-mère
qui qui qui reste tranquille qui paye
ses imp c'est pas forcément les octf les
gens qui sont en situation de
délinquence tu vas dans une je te parle
je te parle des octf en situation de
délinquence on en fait quoi les TF en
situation de dél mais en fait tu prends
pour moi tu prends le problème à
l'envers non tu réponds pas à ma
question si je vais y répondre je vais
répondre je t'assure mais en fait
aujourd'hui on délivre tellement d'qtf
qu'on peut plus les suivre c'est ça la
vérité c'estàd tu regardes le taux
d'exécu en fait on en délivre tellement
tu vois quand je te dis entre la
grand-mère et CETA en fait tu ne sais
pas à l'avance que quelqu'un qui a unetf
et délinquant tu le sais pas forcément
tu as des gens qui sont en situation de
marginalité qui pète un plomb et C donc
tu tu ne le sais pas à l'avance soit tu
vires tout le monde OK ok tu F tout le
monde c'est une politique tu déportes
tout le monde et cetera faut que le pays
accueillant accepte faut que tuas les
moyens de lui forcer tu es pas forcément
Trump hein voilà Macron c'est pas
Trump soit tu te dis que tu essayes
d'intégrer les gens moi je je ne connais
pas de situation intermédiaire ok ceux
qui foutent le bordel on quoi San bah
sanction sanction quo sanction bah ça
dépend du niveau ils sont
archisanctionnés ils sont sanctionnés
une fois deux fois tro fois 4 fois 5
fois 6 fois 7 fois 8 fois 9 fois on fait
quoi
sanction je te sanction quoi on leur
coupe les aloes on fait quoi les de
chezx à quoi ça sert de couper les aloes
pourquoi tu prive les enfants fait
l'avoc ouais non mais je vois bien mais
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait les gamins tu
vois les gamins de ces gens ils ont fait
quoi en fait mais je te dis jeis
responsabiliser les parents euh mais
déjà tu sais tout à l'heure on parlait
de l'aide sociale à l'enfance moi je
veux bien responsabiliser les parents
mais faut commencer par l'État quand il
est parent parce que quand l'État est
parent des gamins lui il est pas
responsable du tout il laisse les gamins
dans des hôtels où il y a aucun
accompagnement et il les laissent dans
leur solitude dans leur déprime et après
tu as des choses notamment à roué où tu
te retrouves avec des gens qui ont des
pathologies mentales et quelqu'un qui
est bipolaire quelqu'un qui est
schizophrène tu peux le mettre en garde
à viUe autant de fois que tu veux vas-y
mets-le en garde à vue si tu veux il va
ressortir comment s'il a pas de suivi et
même ceux qu' ont pas de pathologie
parce que tu vois moi j'aime pas aussi
criminaliser la la pathologie mental il
y a des gens ils ont des pathologies ça
se passe très bien ils ont juste du mal
à eux mais mais quand tu n'as pas de
suivi c'estàd par exemple quand quand
les spipes tu sais les services les
pénitentièires d'insertion et cetera les
conseillers de de réinsertion là où ils
font du carart non c'est pas eux non non
les SPIP c'est en gros les gens qui sont
payés pour faire pour suivre le parcours
quand tu sors de prison par exemple de
réinsertion est-ce que tu as un boulot
est-ce que tu as une copine tu vois qui
qui consignent ça qui sont au courant
quand tu as 20 dossiers tu peux suivre
20 gamins quand tu en as 90 et ben en
fait tuappelles ça va ouais ça va
exactement comme àemploi ça va ouais ça
va c'est ça he qui font les conseillers
maintenant donc tu as pas les moyens
d'une politique de suivi bah c'est bah
les personnes sont dans des situations
effectivement ils peuvent récidiver
s'agissant des ocutf tu rajoutes une
difficulté c'est que quand ils veulent
trouver un boulot mais qu'ils ont pas la
régularisation ils peuvent pas bosser on
crée nous-même des chômeurs c'estd que
moi j'ai des gens dans ma circo je
t'assure ils sont ils bossse dans des
snacks ils demandent pas grand-chose
hein donc ils sont dans leur snack ils
demandent à renouveler leur titre de
séjour et vu que ça prend du temps en
préfecture plus que prévu il y a un trou
noir il y a une période de trou c'est tu
es arrivé au bout de de ton esséance
légale tu as toujours pas le
renouvellement du prochain papier et
dans l'attente ton patron s'il se fait
goer en train de t'employer il a des
sanctions c'est lui qui est donc il donc
il t'emploie plus à part s'il est très
sympa et qu' t'emploie au black et
cetera donc en fait on crée nous-même de
la marginalité c'est ça moi le le le
problème que je vois alors évidemment il
y a des gens tu as raison tu sais
j'habite à roubé il y a de la
délinquence hein je veux dire c'est un
peu non c'est quoi ton taux de
criminalité chez toi je sais pas je je
je pas domicide pour 100000 habitants il
est il est il est beaucoup moins haut
que ce que tu penses
euhro je pense mais att non tu as raison
ah excuse-moi mais il est en fait il y a
une délinquence ordinaire mais par
exemple le trafic externe n'est pas
aussi organisé que dans d'autres villes
le gros du trafic organisé est à l'île
sud pas chez moi nous c'est low coast en
fait tu vois c'est pas Marseille c'est
pas et pourtant on est la ville la plus
pauvre de France c'est c'est pas mamouzu
la ville la plus pauvre tu as raison
France hexagonal tu as raison de le
préciser alors nous on a une spécificité
c'est qu'on a plein d'indicateurs
scolaires et cetera qui sont comparables
aux autres
euh tu as peu d'endroits en France où
c'est comme ça mais scolairement par
exemple l'IPS l'indice depposition
scolaire on a des établissements qui
sont effectivement au même niveau voire
parfois même quel éité ma question quel
été ta question qu'est-ce qu'on fait non
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des des des
situation des des types qui foutent la
merde c'est ça tu as une prison qui
s'appelle ce queedin voilà donc si tu
veux vraiment si tu veux les sanctionner
il y a la prison qui s'appelle ce
queedin moi je te dis juste que le
parcours de réhabilitation il marche pas
non ils ont un au CTF ont les mains en
prison ça nous coûte encore du pognon
cette histoire
donc mais ça coûte le dispositif de
contrôle moi j'aimerais bien que les
gens se rendent compte du coup du
dispositif de contrôle qu'on met sur
tout le prix de ce dispositif de
contrôle de contrôle de de contrôle des
pauvres de contrôle ça nous coûte une
fortune qu'on est incapable d'estimer tu
vois et cette fortune là si tu la
mettais dans d'autres choses dans
d'autres politiques par exemple moi je
considère qu'il y a des
trucs un policier un policier peut pas
résoudre tous les problèmes du monde tu
vois aujourd'hui B aujourd'hui dans les
quartiers ça déjà déjà qui fait déjà
beaucoup trop parce que les policiers
font du social leur rôle ils font pas
que de taper sur les gens hein non mais
c'est pas leur rôle ils font pas que de
te choper au radar il font du social ils
t'aident ils te réconforent ils te
rassurent ils ont pas les moyens de le
faire vraiment tu vois de dans dans dans
des quartier difficile c'est tu passes
pas ton temps non plus à recueillir un
jeunne viens pleurer dans mes bras c'est
pas vrai mais non mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que ils ont même plus le
temps de prendre soin mais tous les
services publics n'ont plus le temps de
prendre soin des gens les UTF les
reconductions à la frontière ils foutent
le bordel
on fait quoi on est mis dans un avion le
pays il en veut pas on en fait quoi sur
les ocutf mais mais je te dis je ne suis
pas pour la double peine c'est simple
donc je je déjà je suis pas pour le
système des ocute qui nous coûte une
blinde et cetera moi je vraiment je suis
pour qu'on accueille et que ça se passe
bien tu vois qu'on mette l'argent dans
dans l'accompagnement des gens qui
veulent bosser qu' des gamins enfin tu
vois voilà maintenant quand ça se passe
mal c'est chez nous qu'on peut le
traiter tu vois on a un système carcéral
si vraiment faut si les gens sont trop
dangereux un système carcéral dont je
suis pas fan hein mais tu as un système
carcéral qui existe tu dispositif ouais
ouais bien sûr sûr quand on dit que la
prison c'est le meilleur endroit pour se
radicalisé religieusement parlant non
c'est les réseaux sociaux c'est les
réseaux sociaux nous ce qu'on a eu à
roué par exemple c'est des phénomènes
soit de réseau soit de famille les
fréiries ouais c'est pas dans les
mosquées en fait hein que ça ser radical
chez nous nous on a bah d'ailleurs on a
eu j'ai eu un sujet très récemment il y
a une maison qui a été abandonnée
c'était la maison de gens qui avaient
fait un départ en Syrie euh c'était une
famille qui recrutait en fait c'était
une sphère familiale après qui je sais
pas comment elle établissait ses réseaux
dans la ville mais tu vois c'était une
famille qui qui recrutait et qui avait
fait un départ qui avait fait un départ
en Syrie donc c'était plus ça ça se
passait comme ça chez nous euh en
général les les
institutions religieuses sont plutôt ce
sont des gens qui veulent pas du tout
des terroristes et cetera la prison ça
peut arriver mais c'est pareil tu
tu ça dépend du les gens qui qui vont
passer à l' sont des gens souvent qui
sont en situation de d'anomie sociale
aucun lien humain aucun contact donc
déjà dès que tu en des tu es dans des
institutions religieuses par contre tu
as des liens humains et ceter tu as des
gens qui disent tu tcnes arrêes arrête
arrête même des gens qui sont très
conservateurs tu vois donc en prison
effectivement si dans ta prison tu es
dans une situation complète d'anomie tu
vois d'explosion sociale où tu es tout
seul et que tu tombes sur le gars qui
devient un repère pour toi oui ok tu vas
recruter mais là aujourd'hui moi c'est
pas c'est pas la prison de ce queedin si
tu veux que se forme le le le terrorisme
international c'est pas pas ça il y a
des il y a des il y a des gens qui sont
très isolés aujourd'hui qui qui sont
recrutés sur les réseaux et pas et pas
des catégories de population qu'on pense
hein des fois c'est souvent des nouveaux
convertis justement qu' on pas d'ancrage
familial qu' on pas justement ce truc
culturel de rapport à la religion
d'aller vérifier dans le liv et cetera
et cetera donc tu te retrouves avec des
Bretons qui partent je dis pas que c'est
la règle de base he mais c'est parfois
c'est nouveaux convertis ou des gens qui
sont bretons de première ou deuxème
génération ah je sais pas non il y a eu
des premières il y a eu des qu il y a eu
des mais je je veux pas stigmatiser les
Bretons hein je te dis juste que en fait
le fondement c'est c'est l'anomie
sociale moi ma vision des choses là
dessus mais sur tous les domaines c'est
plus tu as de liens humains plus tu as
de liens
sociaux plus moins tu deviens violent
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe quand ta
quantité d'énergie
baisse tu parles de quoi de l'énergie du
pays de c'est est-ce que tu vois une
relation de cause à effet entre pic
énergétique et terrorisme ah mais toi tu
m'as dit que tu travaillais là-dessus
juste avant de venir tu m'as dit que tu
travaillais là-dessus bah je je saurais
pas te la dire mais tout ce que je sais
c'est quand un système économique
s'effonde les gens sont livrés à eux
même donc en fait la causalité si tu
veux à mon avis s'il y en a une elle se
situe là c'est dans les situations
d'anomie c'est tu n'as plus de lien et
donc quand tu n'as plus de lien se
développe tous les problèmes de
pathologies et tu es fragile et donc
quand tu es fragile tu es recrutable
mais tu tu mais tu tu deviens tu peux
mais ce que ce que ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que dans cette fragilité les gens
se font souvent du mal à eux-mêmes
vraiment c'est c'est quand même la règle
la plus à leur communauté aussi non non
mais quand je dis du mal au même je
parle des gens qui qui s'automutilent
qui se droguent qui et qui passent pas à
l'acte sur les autres il y en a plein
dont on ne parle pas c'est ça qui me
donc oui après tu as ceux qui font peur
parce qu'effectivement ils sont
dangereux ça oui ok mais ça je peux te
dire va dans une prison tu verras que
euh c'est c'est pas que des populations
de quartier hein c'est pas que ça tu as
des gens en anonomie sociale qui sont
complètement perdus et
et après quand qui développe des
pathologies des trucs et et et la
question c'est à quel moment tu tu alors
oui tu peux choisir des enfermé pour la
vie hein mais tu peux aussi choisir de
se dire bon celi-là peut-être que tu
fais le paril qu'il va arrêter d'être un
peu dangereux si tu si tu l'encadres moi
je suis pour une société où on encadre
les gens c'est pas un truc si tu veux
ouais sort de prison tout va bien ça va
bien se passer on va t'offrir un
logement et tout non c'est tencadre
d'accord non mais plus il y a
d'institionad qu'est-ce que tu fais pour
les gens quand ta balance commerciale
elle à moins de 156 milliards mais alors
moi je t'ai prouvé qu'il y avait de la
tune pendant une heure je je t' prouvé
qu'il y avait de l'argent donc tu
essayes de me faire un budget à
l'équilibre moi j'appelle pas ça tu me
trouves de la tune ça coûte pas très
cher hein Mo Moe un budget à pseudo
équilibre d'accord est-ce que ton budget
ta prévision de budget tu l'as un petit
peu mis sous stress
test que pour les 5 prochaines années tu
l'as mis un peu sur stress lecture comme
ta clé de lecture ou elle est aussi
précise que ma gardienne avec tout le
respect qu' je mais non mais quand on
fait ton budget tu l'as mis sous test
quand on faisait les les
expérimentations sur le le programme
présidentiel notamment on partait sur
des prévisions de déficit ou des
prévisions de croissance différentes
donc on avait les hypothèses hautes les
hypothèses moyennes les hypothèses basse
donc ton stress test c'est tu prends
l'hypothèse basse ou tu prends alors il
y avait pas de scénario catastrophe mais
tu on partait sur des scénarios moyens
en fait vraiment très moyen 2017 et 2022
c'est vraiment et des fois même on
disait tu vois Jean-Luc et tout quand
même tu es prudent quoi tu vois tu es
vraiment prudent donc donc c'est ça nous
la manière dont on modélise tout ça là
quand on fait le budget on modélise pas
sur une croissance à 6 % hein on est sur
les scénarios tu vois c'est-à-dire on
regarde on fait bon bah voilà le déficit
et on part d'un déficit à 6 % qu'est-ce
que ça nous permet de faire qu'est-ce
que ça nous permet de pas faire c'est
comme ça qu'on modélise nos nos
propositions et à partir de là tu verras
qu'il y a des recettes qui peuvent être
dégagées dis-moi est-ce que dans tes
budgets dans tes finances dans tout ça
est-ce que tu as inclus les promesses de
retraite aux fonctionnaires
oui mais parce que les
hautfonctionnaires ils surcotisse les
fonctionnaires ils surcotisent c'est pas
la population la plus difficile à à
inclure ce qui est difficile c'est les
métiers qui
disparaissent par exemple je te donne un
exemple du passé c'est les mineurs ceux
qui étaient dans les mines ils vont
venir bah ouais on va voir mais en tout
cas jusqu'à aujourd'hui l'État est
obligé de compenser à la Scub pour une
raison simple c'est que vu que le métier
a disparu les anciens mineurs qui ont
besoin qu'on leur paye leur trraite sont
restés mais il y avait plus de mineurs
des générations actuelles pour payer le
régime particulier donc là tu dois
mettre de l'argent donc les les si tu
veux les métiers qui disparaissent ouais
les fonctionnaires surcotisent les
fonctionnaires sont vraiment pas la
population qui fait du mal à la sécurité
sociale au contraire moi je trouve que
c'est une justement mais d'ailleurs moi
je suis pour un modèle politique où on
cotise beaucoup plus comme tu dis les
fonctionnaires cotisent c'est l'État qui
cotise pour eux non
bah oui c'est la paye c'est la paye des
fonctionnaires tu as raison c'est la
paye des fonctionnaires et la paye des
fonctionnaires elle sort d'où elle du
pied du cheval impô impôt ressources
publiqu bah oui bien sûr non mais oui
mais après c'est un choix mais moi je
suis pour une société par ailleurs on
surcotise moi si tu veux dans mon it
pour la cotisation par capitalisation la
retraite par capitalisation pourquoi si
on l'avait fait en 1980 on en serait où
là ça dépend si tu comptes les crash ou
pas ouis le problème c'est 4 il fait
quoi là depuis les 30 dernières années
et mais attends ça dépend dans quelle
boîte tu l'as mis hein d'accord ouais
parce que si tu l'as mis dans une boîte
qui se casse la gueule bon courage pour
ta retraite en fait et puis il a il y a
quand même un truc c'est qu'on a un
système vraiment on a inspiré le monde à
un moment c'est moi je vois tu vois même
au state cétait là Michael moour qui
arrivé le système de séu social français
bon ils ont fait un truc un peu médian
pour être gentil avec l'obamaker et tout
mais on on on a un système qui est ultra
robuste il y a des choses dont on
discute jamais en France on se rend pas
compte hein par par exemple sur les
dépenses de l'assurance maladie allez
disons en 2017 ça représentait 10 10 %
des dépenses de l'assurance maladie ce
que je vais te dire c'est les cancers
est-ce que il y a des Français ou est-ce
que les gens alors oui c'est c'est en
explosion aujourd'hui mais est-ce que
les gens qui nous regardent savent
combien ça coûte une chimio savent Pasin
ils savent pas parce que c'est pris la
charge à 100 % alors pas tu payes quand
même des choses tu payes les nuits
d'hôpital par exemple le remboursement
de certains
mdoc les thérapies et cetera mais le le
le la prise en charge médicamenteuse je
crois la la la la chimie en elle-même tu
la payes pas c'est à 100 %. donc les
gens quand ils regardent le modèle D
state ils aiment bien dire ouais ils
gagnent plus tu vois ils ont un salaire
salaire net qui est beaucoup plus élevé
ok le jour où tu as un cancer et vu que
c'est en train d'exploser bon courage le
cancer si tu veux moi j'avais vu des
trucs de 2017 sur la Cour des comptes
c'était entre 5 et 30000 €. traitement
de base 30000 €. si tu veux les
thérapies euh alors faut qu'on faut
qu'on parle des pharmacies quand même
enfin des des tu vois des des grands
domaines de la santé qui peuvent s'en
faire mais tu peux monter si tu veux
vraiment les thérapies qui qui sont les
plus efficaces ouais voilà non mais il
faut le dire aux gens parce que c'est
c'est c'est c'est ça derrière David on
parle international ouais tuux
parlerinnational parce que je te vois à
chaque fois tu dévies je sais tuas tu
essayes d'aider les gens de transmettre
tout ça bon l'international ouais tu
nous vois où la France elle va où dans
les 5 prochaines années
carmondisation si on prend la si on
continue d'emprunter le chemin qu'on a
pris et pourquoi d'ailleurs parce que on
a on a si tu veux la France n'est plus
un empire colonial donc elle a plus les
circuits d'approvisionnement et cetera
qu'elle avait avant donc il y a un
moment en fait faut arrêter de se penser
plus gros que ce qu'on est elle a perdu
tous les avantages et toutes les
positions qu'elle pouvait avoir assez
rapidement d'ailleurs dans ce qui
restait et maintenant on a un problème
de ressources c'est-à-dire que on est
pas fixé sur qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire
de notre énergie sur le renouvelable
nucléaire et ce on n'est pas fixé
sachant que c'est des
technologies que tu pars d'un côé moi je
sur le renouvelable mais que tu pars
d'un côté comme de l'autre ça va prendre
5 10 ans 15 ans donc là on va avoir un
moment qui va être difficile en
industriel ouais euh on va devoir
importer on va avoir une balance
commerciale qui est plus compliquée en
terme d'énergie on a saboté un de nos
géants quif complètement saboté par les
règlements européens mais quelque part
ces défisl ils peuvent être relevés
aussi c'estàdire par exemple EDF
aujourd'hui se fait saboter par le
règlement par les les règlements
européens sur l'électricité qui fait
qu'en fait F est obligé de vendre son sa
propre électricité au privé moins cher
et le privé peut revendre son
électricité à EDF donc là tu es sur un
fonctionnement où on sabote notre géant
national et on a tendance à saboter nos
nos fleuron la SNCF c'est qui on bah les
politiques
européenne appliqué par les dirigeants
français leur
administration transport on en parle peu
mais la SNCF qui qui qui et la RATP
d'ailleurs métro train donc qui est
quand même le ticket de méro le ticket
de métro il est augmenté de combien là
là il est à 2 € et quelques là moi je
suis à pasnvigo je prends moins
90 sur le mois euh ouais je moins 89 ou
moins 80 continue j'ai fait exprès
continue ah tu voulais me tester ch qu'
non mais parce qu'en fait le prix de la
baillette nonutilise TR le métro moi je
suis resté sur le prix de la baguette à
70 mais je sais que après ça dépend si
tuas roué ou pas aussi le prix de la
baguette est moins cher à rou il faut
venir à rouber euh parce qu'elle est
bonne en plus non mais donc par exemple
en terme de transport on a les
règlements européens ont obligé la SNCF
vu qu'on n pas le droit à des monopoles
à être décarcassé en trois quoi en trois
pôles fret
réseau ça aussi ça nous pose des
problèmes le fret est en train de se
casser la gueule alors que si tu veux
faire du transport de marchandis
écolo bah faut réalimenter le réseau
faut refaire passer les petites lignes
et faut faut faut convertir les rails
pour qu'il soient à des distances
suffisantes pour les roues et cetera que
c'est pas les mêmes et aujourd'hui les
camions sont en train de gagner sauf que
les camions maîtriseent pas voilà les
camions c'est la Pologne c'est tu vois
on maîtrise pas du tout le transport le
transport par camion donc là on est
mauvais et en plus ces boîtesl qui sont
à fleuron qui sont en capacité de gagner
des marchés à l'étranger à la base ont
de plus en plus de difficultés du coup à
gagner des marchés c'est-à-dire que le
métro tu as des coopérations entre la
RATP et d'autres pays la SNCF a fait des
coopérations avec plein d'autres pays
pour faire des réseaux et pour fournir
ça ce qui représente pour des
entreprises publiques possédées par
l'état des dividendes en plus par
exemple ou des rentrées d'argent ça
aussi on s'en prive industrie j'ai très
peur sur l'année qui arrive à cause de
justement la surproduction chinoise sur
l'acier je suis très je suis vraiment je
pense que nous on a une assie notamment
enfin en tout cas tout ce qui est le
complexe à d'unkererc par exemple qui
est en grave danger donc Arcelor mital
et compagnie là c'est c'est nous ce que
nous disent les syndicats quoi hein je
je j'invente pas la chose mais ce que
nous dis disent les syndicats c'est
qu'en gros c'est des plans de
licenciement de massif qui s'annonce
Michelin massif c'est quoi massif bah là
on est sur du 3000 4000 emplois je pense
au moins juste chez moi enfin dans le
Michelin Michelin ClermontFerrand qui
commence déjà à licencier massivement
donc plusieurs milliers d'emplois
également sur le carreau et puis bon
après tu as ça c'est pas c'est moins sur
le lourd du lourd mais tu as un modèle
aussi qui s'effondre le modèle des
grandes surfaces commerciales un modèle
urbain on en parle pas assez d'ailleurs
des modèles urbains je trouve que c'est
un truc
mais euh tout autour de chez moi c'est
là qu' y avait les premiers auchamp et
compagnie c'est la galaxie mulié hein
ils étaient à roubés ça les surfaces
commerciales ça marche plus non plus
donc faut s'attendre à à une situation
difficile mais par exemple les surfaces
commerciales marchent plus ça va être
très difficile du point de vue de
l'emploi mais on peut aussi réinventer
des modèles tu vois tu n'es pas obligé
de rester statique par rapport à la
catastrophe ce que je réfléchis à roubé
par exemple en ce moment c'est à se dire
comment tu recrées des centralités des
places du village avec l'implantation de
commerce ou de passage qui ne coûte pas
si cher parce que tu te trpes parce que
le privé peut investir en fait aussi
là-dessus c'est pas obligé d'être l'État
qui qui investit partout centrale
d'achat qui négocient tes prix les moins
chers ah bah nous on a on a on a des
centrales d'achat qui qui alimentent
beaucoup les petits les petits
restaurateur donc eux eux c'est clair
que c'est le moindre coût quoi voilà
c'est le moindre coût donc la moindre
qualité derrière en terme de tu vois par
je sais plus comment ça s'appelle là où
on achète la nourriture là c'est les
restaurateurs qui se métro ouais métro
eux c'est bon eux leur modèle pour
l'instant il est à mon avis il marche
même si je connaais pas très bien mais
là je te parlais plus de de comment tu
tu tu fais en sorte que là tu vas avoir
des espaces vides en France tu vois côté
de chez moi c'est peut-être qui va se
passer dans quelques années en fait va y
avoir des espaces entiers qu'on a
construit tu sa le modèle de Melin des
nouvelles villes ou autre où en fait les
grandes surfaces commerciales sont plus
rentables pourquoi elles sont plus
rentables prix de l'électricité prix du
foncier euh plein de choses voilà mais
sur ta trajectoire de rarfaction des
ressources et tu peux reconstruire des
choses par exemple moi je je je j'estime
que dans chaque quartier de ta ville la
puissance publique elle va pas créer de
A à Z la centralité d'un petit quartier
mais tu peux recréer des espaces quelque
part des places du village tu vois tu
peux recréer le fait que les gens
transitent tu peux tu peux créer le flux
par exemple tu peux orienter le flux
dans ta ville ça c'est quelque chose que
tu peux faire si tu en as la volonté ça
va pas toujours marcher et à partir du
moment où il y a du flux bah un
commerçant qui voit que les gens passent
au même endroit qu'est-ce qu'il fait il
s'installe là un commerçant qui veut les
gens passer au M r en voiture en vélo à
pied à pied en vélo en voiture tout ce
que tu veux tu t'installes là voilà
question et une fois que tu t'es
installé là après tu mets le guichet
social question quels effets ont les
choix politiques de Trump sur l'Europe
sur la France euh
en fait là il y a un effet de j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a un effet de
sidération c'estàd que beaucoup de
responsables ne se rendent pas compte de
de ce qui se passe de sidération ou de
catatonie ouais je sais pas comment le
dire mais j'ai l'impression que tout le
monde est comme ça là tu vois dans dans
les sphères européennes et tout et et ce
par tu parles qu'est-ce que tu appelles
les sphères européennes tu parles de la
bande de crétins qui sont capables de
faire une stratégie militaire
d'anticiper les flux logistiques
d'anticiper les flux d'approvisionnement
tu parles de cette bande de Cré et
surtout ils se rendent pas compte que le
protectionnisme et surtout ils se
rendent pas compte que les Américains
ont toujours fait un système
protectionniste toujours c'estd qu'en
fait les Américains quand ils font un
produit ils font pas le protectionnisme
après il y a un produit américain et en
fait leur protectionistme ils vont
mettre tu sais ils vont dire bah tiens
tel produit je sais pas de circuit
informatique doit être designé comme ça
et en fait le comme ça c'est quoi c'est
juste le produit qui existe déjà en
Amérique et on fait comme ça et tu es
sûr que tu as le marché parce que c'est
designé pour que ça marche comme ça quoi
donc les américains ils sont très forts
à ça et là en plus de ça va y avoir des
prétensions territoriales sur le
Groenland et sur les circuits
d'approvisionnement bah tu sais c'est un
continent donc ils ont leur gaz de
chiste ils ont leur et nous on va être
incapable
d'exporter sans se faire cartonner voilà
en terme de balance commerciale je sais
pas comment on va finir je sais pas les
les Allemands vont avoir de plus en plus
de mal avec leur industrie parce qu'ils
en ont une c'est l'automobile ça devient
compliqué tu vois de plus en plus de
Tesla dans la rue et cetera là en ce
moment euh donc ils se disent bah
peut-être en Amérique du Sud sauf que
vis-àvis de l'Amérique du Sud tu vois
comment Trump commence à se comporter
avec le Mexique et et la Colombie je
sais pas comment ça va finir pour être
honnête
donc donc là l'effet ça va être à mon
avis l'effet de ciseau là entre la Chine
et la Russie surproduction chinoise et
et et protectionnisme américain face
encore une fois tout ça n'est il y a pas
de fatalité par exemple on n'est pas
obligé à ce que notre marché soit aussi
ouvert que ça est-ce qu'on est les
dindons de la farce bah si tu veux on
est les premiers consommateurs mondiaux
on narrive pas à consommer notre
production j'ai l'impression c'est quand
même bizarre voilà on a de l'argent on a
on a un marché intérieur les Européens
sont pas capables de prendre conscience
aussi de leur force he parce qu'on a des
attributs on est géographiquement on a
des attributs démographiquement on a des
attributs la composition sociale de
l'Europe est pas trop mal non mais voilà
on a on a quand même on n'est pas
condamné à ça mais juste si tu
considères qu'il faut ouvrir toutes les
frontières commerciales et cetera c'est
fini voilà on va se faire manger mais
moi j'ai pas envie d'avoir un discours
si tu veux de dire Sumi moi je fais de
la poétique pour que quelque part pour
aussi donner un
horizon voilà donc donc donc l'horizon
c'est tu peux investir avec avec tous
les trucs un peu lourds que j'ai dit au
début mais tu peux reconstruire une
stratégie industrielle faut faire des
choix moi par exemple je je je postule
pour le renouvelable mais tu peux à
partir de l'argent supplémentaire qu'on
dégage si tu veux faire du nucléaire tu
peux enfin tu vois tu on n'est pas
condamné à ça on a on pourrait avoir un
marché rique franchement qui tient
encore un petit peu la route on pourrait
investir soit soit pour renouveler le
nucléaire soit pour faire de la
transition écologique et cetera comme tu
veux ouais mais toi tu crois pas mais
mais le choix est ouvert le choix est
ouvert les gens te voient pas faire du
violon c'est pas une question d'y croire
ou pas y croire c'est les
éoliennes les panneaux solaires du
charbon transmuté en panneau
solaireCe tu racontes là les
renouvelablebl de quoi tu m'aurais parlé
d'hydraulique d'hydraulique bah déjà bah
attends peut-être un peu de géothermie
mais le reste mais d'ailleurs Mélenchon
tu sais il parle beaucoup d'Hydro
beaucoup de géothermie beaucoup
d'hydraulique parce que je pense qu'en
terme de rendement énergétique c'est
mieux voilà donc après c'est vrai hein
tu là aujourd'hui c'est le pétrole le
rendement énergétique le pétrole c'est
comment tu analyses le fait que euh
l'Union européenne est financer des des
des assos d'écolo pour faire pression
pour faire passer le Green Deal faire
pression sur contrôle nucléaire comment
tu analyse l'Allemagne qui nous met des
crochpades sur notre système
nucléaire c'est quoi c'est de la guerre
économique ils avaient peur qu'on soit
trop compétitif par rapport à eux ils
ont préféré nous démonter les genoux
maintenant on leur fil du nucléaire on
est gentil quand même avec les Allemands
pourquoi on n pas envoyé purement et
simplement permettez-moi l'expression
pourquoi on n pas envoyé chier les
Allemands ils savent pas gérer ils sont
prétentieux ils nous ont passons
l'expression ils nous ont mis des gros
coups de tatane derrière la tête
maintenant il se retrouve le bec dans
l'eau alors Macron est gentil il est
européen il nous sort pas du système
électrique européen parce que sinon les
Allemands se vautrent et nous emmènent
dans le trou avec la France a jamais
quoi su faire avec l'Allemagne jamais si
on a su quoi faire à un moment non on n
jamais su géré la puissance au milieu du
continent franchement quand tu on na
jamais su gérer et depuis la
réunification on ne sait pas gérer en
fait
euh on n jamais su depuis la
réunification de l'Allemagne
c'est-à-dire depuis la reconstitution si
tu veux du du du mastodonte d'une
puissance qui en plus qui est
industrielle et cetera euh on n'a jamais
su faire autrement d'ailleurs à gauche
et comme à droite la gauche a fait une
erreur fondamentale de se dire bon ils
se sont ils se sont réunis hein ça c'est
c'est le peuple allemand souverain qu'il
décide donc j'ai rien à dire là-dessus
mais ils se sont réunis et quelque part
faut faire l'Europe pour qu'il soit dans
la table des négo ciation faut
absolument pas que l'Allemagne se
redevienne de manière autonome et
reprenne ses prétenions impérialistes
donc c'était moi je te dis moi c'est
c'est pas mais l'erreur de nos anciens
elle est là voilà gauche droite l'erreur
de nos anciens est là parce que en fait
les Allemands ont complètement imposé
ont placé leur pion politique humain
industriel dans l'Europe et surtout ils
ont placé leur idéologie donc voilà ils
étaient traumatisés par l'inflation
baiss donc déjà tu as plus de politique
monétaire enfin maintenant on en a une
par la force des choses parce que là la
garde vient d'abaisser les taux
directeurs mais mais en vrai faut
surtout pas avoir de politique
monétaire faut surtout pas avoir
d'inflation donc pas d'investissement
faut protéger les pensions de retraite
de la population âgée allemande donc
faut un €o tu donc c'est ça qui se passe
vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne et de la France
c'est cette erreur fondamentale là qu'on
a toujours pas réglé et le problème
c'est que tu as raison Macron il est
très gentil il est très gentil voilà il
est on est dans l'incapacité d'assumer
un rapport de force en se disant mais
mais l'Europe c'est la paix et cetera
sur des enfin vraiment moi j'ai des j'ai
je revois souvent des discours y compris
des dirigeants politiques que j'ai en
face des mois sur des plateaux l'Europe
c'est la paix l'Europe c'est la
coopération et ca on a on n'est pas en
coopération c'est pas vrai on peut faire
des coopérations bien sûr mais si tu
veux les intérêts nationaux sont là
l'Allemagne elle est pas tourné vers les
intérêts nationaux de la France donc en
fait quand on produit de l'électricité
est-ce qu'elle est est-ce qu'elle est
tourné vers les les intérêts
européens l'Allemagne est tournée vers
les intérêts en vrai est-ce qu'il faut
sortir de est-ce qu'il faut sortir la
France de l'Europe bah ça c'est la
question du frexit si tu veux moi
je on a souvent été mais je crois que tu
en as parlé avec ERC d'ailleurs plan a
plan B c'est-à-dire en gros il y a un
moment où nous ce qu'on analyse c'est
que la France est est en capacité
de se faire respecter dans le
fonctionnement actuel de l'Union
européenne avec toutes les discussions
après sur la bureaucratie européenne et
ce mais il n'empêche que quand même tu
tu peux imposer des conditions comme a
pu le faire l'Angleterre à un moment des
optout c'està-dire tu sors tu sors de
certaines conditions voilà qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont faire en fait il y a un
moment c'est ça la question c'est si je
le fais qu'est-ce que tu vas faire si je
fais du du htout l'Angleterre l'a fait
pendant des années et ça passé parce
qu'on se disait bah oui mais
l'Angleterre est une pu spécial vous
comprenez elle est tourné vers
l'Atlantique quelque part elle a pas de
prétention sur le continent donc elle
fait un peu ce qu'elle veut bah bah nous
on peut le faire
aussi le rôle de la Banque centrale
c'est pareil tu tu tu moi je crois qu'on
a pas si on arrive pas à faire tout ça
effectivement la question se pose la
question se pose de sortir mais d'abord
tu construis le rapport de force voilà
aujourd'hui la France c'est pas dans une
optique de construire un rapport de
force avec l'Allemagne regarde regarde
le Mercosur comment on se fait
franchement hein
c'est il passent en force euh euh
bagnoles ouais pour aller vendre des
bagnoles en Amérique du Sud et nous nos
paysans ils vont se ils vont se manger
la concurrence de bœuf brésilien et
cetera nourrir aux hormones donc donc
regarde comment ça se passe sur le
Mercosur c'est-à-dire que que ils sont
là et et la Commission européenne
accompagne totalement et je sais même
pas si on arrivera à trouver une
minorité de blocage parce que c'est ça
l'objectif aujourd'hui on fait quoi avec
l'OTAN on en sort on en sort alors là
pour le coup ça on a toujours été clair
là-dessus jour 1 on sort c'est jour 1 où
on prend le pouvoir on sort de
l'OTAN les États-Unis d'Amérique sont
moi malgré l'amitud pour le peuple et
c'est quand même l'Empire le
plus le plus déstabilisateur de
l'histoire de l'humanité j'ai si tu fais
de la Pax Americana mais mais attends
mais les Américains il vont font quoi
ils vont nous faire la guerre nous on a
nous on a une puissance nucléaire déjà
je suis désolé bah oui mais on peut pas
nous faire la guerre comme ça on peut
pas nous envahir comme ça c'est c'est ça
compte dans la discussion ça suffit pas
on a une capacité de projection faible
par exemple militairement
mais notre intégrité elle est conservée
pour
l'instant donc déjà tu prends àquit de
ça moi je je si tu veux le le les
Américains ne ne ne ne nous entraînent
et encore heureux qu'on est résisté une
ou deux fois mais nous entraînne dans un
truc complètement destructeur
c'est-à-dire que eux ils sont en train
de perdre une guerre en Ukraine il sont
en train de la perdre ils font pas la
guerre les Américains en Ukraine ah ils
font par argent ils mettent un peu
d'argent quand même dans l'Ukraine tu
parles de proxy ouais ouais non mais
pourquoi il ferait la guerre en Ukraine
c'est intéressant quel est quel est ton
prisme de lecture sur l'Ukraine c'est le
centre de l'chiquier contenir la Russie
contenir la Russie contenir la Russie
toujours après moi je suis contre
l'invasion de la Russie en Ukraine je le
dis aussi c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment il
y a la souveraineté des peuples et ce
mais mais le plan de l'ANT depuis le
début c'était ça reposait sur une
promesse faite à l'URSS de dire bon ok
vous vous démantelez c'est nous qui
avons gagné mais quelque part on va vous
laisser votre glacie défensif quoi tu
vois les pays qui entourent pour votre
intégrité territoriale euh je pense que
les Russes ont cru et en fait d'né en
année tu vois que les bases militaires
avancent d'année en année donc en fait
quand tu es dans ton jardin et que tu
vois derrière la clôture un type puis le
lendemain 10 puis le lendemain 50 devant
la clôture ils font rien mais ils sont
50 devant ta clôture ils te regardent
euh ça peut pas bien se passer et donc
la Russie s'est mis à faire un choix que
moi je déplore parce que c'était pas la
réponse mais à faire une réponse
militaire euh qu'on qu'on sentait venir
quand même pas tous d'ailleurs mais
qu'on sentait venir donc voilà moi j'ai
condamné cette invasion mais mais tu le
sentais venir donc ça ça a toujours été
la chose et ensuite vu que c'est une
puissance impériale elle a besoin de
maintenir si tu veux le l'acheminement
de ses circuit de production la
cheminement de ses de ses ressources la
Chine fait exactement pareil en ce
moment du point de vue économique hein
les routes de la soie c'est pas pour le
plaisir de retrouver si tu veux c'est
voilà faut que çaut faut que les
circuits commerciaux transitent et
bientôt pour la Route de la Soie
d'ailleurs parce que si tu veux si je me
souviens bien ça passe par le sud de
l'Inde ça reprend tout ça et c'est là où
tu as toutes les hydrocarbures qui
veulent exploiter et compag c'est
beaucoup plus simple que ça c'est que
les Américains ont sécurisé le collier
de perles et que le collier de perles
c'était la première Route des Chinois
pour exporter et ils sont dit oh là là
si les Américains s'amusent à nous
mettre la 8e ou la 15e flotte là on est
cuit ouais oui mais ils vont devoir
c'est bientôt c'est là que va y avoir
des problèmes c'est en fait l'Empire
commercial en soi tout le monde trouve
ça bon se disent ah les chinois ils sont
là ils s'installent en en paix bon c'est
pas totalement vrai par ailleurs mais
bientôt quand tu as une route
commerciale après tu la sécurises et
c'est là qu' y a les problèmes de
militaire qui commencent à se poser
vraiment tu connais les croisades les
croisades et tu sais qu'un de mes
premiers livres que j'avais lu c'était
les croisades vu par les Arabes d'Amine
malouf que j'avais beaucoup aimé je je
cé un de mes premiers livre j'adorais ce
j'adorais ce livre et j'adorais voir la
manière dont justement il renversa par
rapport aux population qui qui se
prenait ça en pleine
tête et on sortait du point de vue
occidental et c'est ce qui manque à la
France c'est qu'elle n'arrive pas à
sortir d'un point de vue ultra
francocentré sur une espèce de nostalgie
de de tout ce qu'on a fait de pire en
plus parce que l'empire colonial tu vois
quelle est la gloire à tout ça on a
construit des routes en Algérie des
hôpitaux des aéroports des systèmes
d'eau je fais la VO du en massacrant
tout le monde la quoi en massacrant tout
le monde ouais c'estàdire qu'en fait
c'est bien d'avoir un hôpital mais quand
tes médecins ils se sont fait tuer et
que les infirmières ont été violés ça
sert à quoi ça c'est ce qu'a dit Marine
Le Pen hier mais tu vois c'est ça à quoi
ça sert en fait donc et encore en plus
les hôpitaux et cetera il y a encore
plein de trucs à dire mais ilst ils ont
ils ont massacré tout le monde c'est ça
la vérité on et on a du mal à se rendre
compte du mal qu'on a fait à l'Algérie
en vérité on n arrive pas à se le dire
parce qu'en fait on a c'est une guerre
qui a été perdue par la France oh on a
fait quelques essais nucléaires là-bas
explosion du des cas de cancer là-bas
non mais c'est c'est donc on a des
choses à l'acteur très connu qui est
mort après avoir tourné un truc ah je
sais pas il y en a un ou il y en a il
fait un tournage de western ou un truc
comme ça ou
euh il y a encore des particul r moi je
pensais équip de tournage
euh euh revenons à nos moutons ouais la
géopolitique l'utant donc on en sort ça
je t'ai répondu euh on fait quoi mais on
fait ce qu'on a fait de mieux dans
l'histoire de notre pays c'est d'être
non aligné c'est-à-dire qu'en fait la
France est en capacité parfois de faire
des trucs avec les Américains je dis pas
qu'il faut rompre les liens mais juste
d'être dans des comme n'importe quel
pays souverain le frais c'est-à-dire de
de savoir soulever des opportunités de
les saisir donc si à un moment tu dois
commercer avec les Américains ou avoir
un accord avec les Américains tu le fais
si un moment c'est avec les Chinois tu
le fais avec les Chinois et puis
franchement vis-à-vis de l'Afrique et de
la Francophonie qui est quand même un
continent qui est très déçu de ce qu'on
peut faire parce qu'on les méprise enfin
en tout cas nos dirigeants les méprisent
ostensiblement mais c'est des gens qui
ont plein de choses à nous apporter donc
tu fais des partenariats avec eux et
puis après on a quand même là bon les
restes de l'empire colonial mais on a un
domaine maritime énorme on a des
frontières communes avec l'Amérique du
Sud on a on a des Don on a des lanceurs
de de de
fusées dans dans les outremers on a
plein de choses sur lesquelles on peut
avancer sur l'exploration des faux-mins
sur l'exploitation des faux-marins s'il
faut enfin voilà et ça c'est la France
si tu veux tel qu' a toujours été et
c'est aussi la France qui donne àoir
quelque chose d'elle au au peuple du
monde parce que moi je crois aussi aux
idées je crois aussi à la force des
idées c'est il y a pas que la force
brute c'est pas vrai ça n'a jamais
marché comme ça les les tu connais
l'ordre mélien non tu de vrais mais les
ordres mais mais l'ordre m lien non je
connais pas je t'expliqueasy toi avec
ton physique chétif je me lève je t'en
mets une tu bouges pas ça dépend tu
monte sur le ring à roué viens tu ouais
bah je j'ai pas fait de box V écout-moi
écoute-moi tu vas morfler donc fais pas
ton malin l'ordre m lien c'est le plus
fort le plus fort et dit comme Trump il
a dit à la Colombie à ses copains tu
prends tes qtf sinon je te mets 25 % de
Dr Donou puis si tu es pas content tu
voas c'est quoi ce FAFO
faround tu connais l'expression found F
out find out fais le con tu vas
comprendre oua ouais ben tu sais tu sais
cet ordre là ordre m lien c'est le plus
fort
ok et les talibans ils ont fait quo ils
ont pris ouais les taliban ils ont pris
quoi de ton ordreélien ils l'ont pris
ouais ouais derrière les taliban il y
avait qui bah il y avait les Russes il y
avait mais mais
attends quand même he non non non non
non nous on a perdu contre
l'Algérie il y a énormément de guerres
que les empires ont pas remporté du tout
du tout et si tu veux dans les moments
de l'histoire par M look mais mais
attends mais dans toutes les histoires
en fait des fois on s enfin faut se
rendre compte des fois tu tu te fais
battre par des armées un peu pouilleuses
quoi je sais pas comment te dire mais
mais c'est une constante de l'histoire
de l'humanité que la force brute ne
règle pas tout alors oui tu as raison tu
crois que notre armée pouilleuse elle va
aller au Grenland faire quoi elle va
aller nourrir les pingouins et dire à
Trump tu restes là-bas non notre armée
seule est pas en capacité de battre mais
par contre il y a un moment tu peux pas
créer la guerre avec l'Europe c'estàdire
en fait si si un moment tu postes le
simple fait de poster des soldats
d'empêcher physiquement de passer moi je
sais pas comment tu règles la guerre
voilà tu vois je suis pas sûr que les
États-Unis il nonont plus toalement les
moyens de faire ça vis-à-vis des
partenaires européens je suis pas sûr du
tout voilà il y a un moment tu mets des
gens tu as plus de gaz de chiste mais
attends tu tu mets des soldats mais
vas-y entre enfin je veux dire mais dans
ce cas-là regarde quand il y a eu la
guerre du Golf on pouvait plus utiliser
nos catapultes de porte-avion parce
qu'il y avait un petit composant mine
amerriica dedans ouais ouais c'est vrai
non mais tu as raison c'est une
puissance impériale donc mais quand tu
es le Mexique c'est très difficile parce
que tu es aux portes ils auront déjà
piqué une partie de leur territoire en
c'est ça la vérité aussi mais quand tu
es le Mexique c'est c'est c'est très dur
de résister à la puissance impériale ça
je suis d'accord avec toi quand tu es la
Colombie c'est très dur quand tu es mais
ils sont fait per ils sont fait pouiller
par Cuba ceci dit hein pas oublier non
ils sont fait pouiller par les Russes
qui instrumentalisai que c'est pas vrai
la révolution cubaine c'est une
révolution de libération nationale au
début les Russes mettent pas un centime
dedans pas un centime ils y croient pas
ils disent en même temps c'est vrai que
tu te dis mais tu es au porte de
l'Empire tuas quelques kilomètres bon
ils se disent on va pas non plus
dépenser tout notre argent dessus les
russes arrivent à après en fait dans la
r Cuba avec les sanctions là bah voilà
donc là tu as la loi Verton et cetera
mais ce que je veux te dire c'est que
c'est pas vrai que l'empire est destiné
à gagner tout le temps voilà ça n'est
pas vrai tu penses que la population
européenne est prête à à prendre des
sanctions des États-Unis la population
je suis pas sûr tu as raison la
population européenne je suis pas sûr
euh elle a pas été super prête vis-à-vis
de la Russie déjà en vérité et euh et
après ça dépend des pays parce que par
exemple quand tu mets des sanctions nous
les français je pense pas qu'on se vit
comme en conflit avec les États-Unis et
que donc l'opinion publique même
comprendrait que donc tu dois préparer
le terrain tu dois tu dois en parler
mais c'est ton rôle de responsable
politique d'anticiper tout ça mais
clairement quand tu es quand tu es par
exemple quand tu veux prendre des S
politique et anticipation dans la même
phrase tu fais très fort quand même
désolé de te faire rire mais par exemple
quand tu
es même si je suis pas d'accord avec la
mentalité et cetera mais quand aux
Polonais tu leur dis faut se préparer
des sanctions contre la Russie eux je
pense qu'ils sont un peu plus près voilà
donc ils ont peu plus peur bien sûr mais
c'est pour ça mais mais ils sont aussi
un peu plus conscients des enux jeu que
ça représente pour eux nous le problème
c'est un bout de l'Ukraine les les
polonaisment ils veulent un bout de
l'Ukraine les
Polonais je crois pas je crois pas mais
je me trompe peut-être mais je crois pas
je pense pas que ça soit sal en jeu
aujourd'hui parce que en fait ils
veulent surtout contenir l'avancée russe
je pense que c'est ça leur je pense que
l'Ukraine fait tampon plutôt mais bon je
me trompe peut-être he je mais euh mais
nous on vit depuis enfin depuis 70 ans
avec l'idée que les États-Unis c'est une
c'est nos alliés c'est nos amis pas
juste nos alliés en fait nos
amis faud que tu relise rmon Haron c'est
pas nos amis comment c'est pas nos amis
je veux dire le peuple américain oui il
y a des échanges et cetera mais mais on
se sent en proximité avec eux
culturellement et cetera mais mais du
point de vue géopolitique les États-Unis
d'Amérique ne sont pas nos amis voilà ça
c'est un c'est un
fait il voit il voit l'Europe comme un
truc à prendre il le voit comme ça et là
moi j'ai très peur de ce qui va se
passer en plus avec la troï sur
l'Allemagne ou autre parce que c'est ça
la suite FMI F bah Troika
FMI c'est ça la suite là vis-à-vis de
l'Allemagne d'ailleurs c'est marrant ça
nous laisse du temps à la France parce
que je pense qu'il vont commencer par
l'Allemagne en vérité parce que
l'Allemagne c'est plus juteux comme
marché en vrai il y a des industries il
y a du il y a du truc lourd quoi il il y
a de l'argent à prendre et il y a des
trucs à vendre il y a des trucs à vendre
faire
pas par comme je t'ai dit on sait pas
comment gérer avec l'Allemagne mais mais
moi j'ai pas du tout envie que
l'Allemagne tuis ça sera une catastrophe
pour l'Europe en vrai que le système
Industri allemle surtout pour l'UR
question la transition énergétique
l'écologie tu crois ou c'est encore du
du
bullshit d'c gogo vert qui fait caca
dans la S
bah attends moi il y a en fait il y a
des enjeux concrets quoi il y a des
enjeux concrets r rarfaction de la
ressources en
eau intensification des phénomènes
météorologiques enfin donc tu as des
choses concrètes à organiser là du point
de vue notamment moi ce qui me le truc
où je suis un peu le moins concerné
parce que je viens toute ma vie j'ai
fait ça dans la dans l'urbain mais qui
qui commence à m'agiter c'est la
question agriculture manger manger tu es
AR roubé tu es quand même bien AC le
réchau climatique tu te rends pas compte
le prix de l'immobilier comment il vait
exploser chez tu as bien raison ouis
ouais ouais ouais non mais tu attends
mais faut pas le dire parce que après
les Parisiens ils arrivent ils achètent
les apparts de matre les maisons de
matre ils les coupent en quatre ils les
revendent donc faut pas le dire mais
effectivement roué on n pas trop mal
niveau température mais après on va
avoir des soucis par exemple on a de
plus en plus de phénomènes
météorologiques pluie d'iluvienne et
cetera si nos sols ils sont pas préparés
à absorber l'eau ça risque d' risque
quand même d'y avoir des problèmes tu
vois on n'est pas immunisé contre ça
mais c'est clair queon on sera il fera
moins chaud bon il peut faire très
froid donc mais après nous de toute
façon la ville en elle-même ok mais par
contre dans le Nord si tes champs de
patates ils sont gelés euh ou gelés
prématurément avant que la saison arrive
tu vois juste après des bourgeodement ou
autre tu vas avoir un souci donc nous on
a moi moi je crois pas que ça soit un
délire dans l'écologie on parle souvent
de de nucléaire pas nucléaire mais moi
il y a des trucs très concrets que je
vois c'est gestion des déchets gestion
de l'eau canalisation réseau enfin c'est
bête mais par exemple les canalisations
elle fuiti en France on perd une
ressource en eau considérable parce que
no nos canalisations sont percées et ça
et ça n'est pas un problème public
aujourd'hui sauf que même en terme
d'argent public enfin d'argent privé
parce qu'en fait mais mais en terme
d'argent là moi je vois un souci
considérable voilà c'est des choses
concrètes que tu peux avancer pour moi
c'est pas du tout du ressort de de
l'utopie gestion des déchets
réutilisables et cetera moi je viens
d'une ville si tu veux où le textile
c'était euh bah je suis désolé mais
aujourd'hui tu tu tu fais venir des
textiles de de Chine donc de de la Chine
bangladesch euh Bangladesh Chine et
cetera fast fast fashion donc en fait en
un jour tous les jours se renouvelle une
gamme donc c'est c'est bien pour les
pour les gamins et les gamines ok je
peux comprendre mentalement l'état
d'esprit dans lequel ils sont sauf que
ça ne va pas donc faut au moins pouvoir
réutiliser ça plutôt que de l' jeter
parce queà chaque fois que tu fais un
pantalon pareil tu tu as une
consommation en eau tu as une
consommation alors c'est pas nous qui la
payons c'est les petits au bangladesch
dans des conditions sociales et
écologiques désastreuses mais il
n'empêche qu'on est responsable de ça
parce que ça nous concerne donc là tu
vois par exemple sur le textile sur la
récupération du textile on pourrait être
dans des circuits pionniers et je dis ça
parce que aujourd'hui sur le textile moi
j'ai j'ai les amis de la Lainière qui
font des trucs dessus et la laère
c'était une usine o il y avait 100 10000
ouvriers à l'époque he c'était il y
avait des carentiers qui venaient où il
y avait les
familles pas ah non je crois pas je
crois pas je crois pas qu'il y avait des
famill dedans je je regarderai si tu
veux mais je crois pas mais mais par
exemple tu as des enjeux liés au textile
tout à fait immédiat du style le carbone
carbone tu habilles des tu tu tu crées
des composants pour les fuser avec du du
textile de style carbone donc c'est pas
des petits enjeux en fait tu as des
matériaux de haute technologie qui ont
besoin de textile c'est vrai que moi au
début quand on avaiton spatiale quoi ben
ah non non non non tu tu tu es sur des
enrobages de fusé et cetera sur des sur
des lanceurs des réacteurs tu en fait le
tu as des textiles qui sont d'une
résistance ou d'une propriété hyper
solide donc tout ça c'est des enjeux à
faire en fait les les zones à faible
émission la transition énergétique ZFE
catastrophe pour moi mais alors dans mon
territoire spécialement dans tous les
territoires populaires banlieu campagne
et cetera catastrophe parce Queen fait
tu es en train de dire aux gens que le
véhicule critère je sais pas combien
n'est plus utilisable et que du coup il
faut changer de voiture sauf que comme
je t'ai dit moi chez moi par exemple
j'ai 46 % de taux de pauvreté donc en
fait les gens n'ont pas l'argent pour
changer de véhicule ils ont pas d'argent
pour pour pour faire tu vois la prime à
la casse et cetera ça ne suffit pas en
fait si tu veux aujourd'hui des critères
qui soit qui respectent vraiment les
afeux donc en fait tu vas te retrouver
avec quoi soit les pouvoirs publics font
semblant c'est-à-dire qu'ils vont pas
sanctionner c'est ça il y a peut-être
des consignes qui vont donné à la police
c'est parce que sinon tu arrêtes ton
système économique dans une ville comme
roubé enfin tu vois il y a des y a des y
a des gens qui ne peuvent plus aller au
boulot soit tu encorche complètement les
les les les transports publics parce que
là il y a un déport qui est pas du tout
préparé moi je suis pour le transport
public par exemple mais aujourd'hui dans
la métropole de Lille c'est pas vrai que
le métro il est prêt à accueillir autant
de gens il est déjà bondé H24 enfin H24
sur les heures de pointe c'est bondé
bondé bondé il y a plein de déraillement
donc tu paralyses des circuits
économiques en fait quand tu bloques les
circulations donc moi les ZFE c'est un
truc antisocial si tu veux de gens pour
qui c'est facile d'acheter une voiture
en fait dans leur tête c'est facile on
va changer tu prends la petite prime le
machin ça marche pas comme ça moi le
le mon collaborateur qui s'appelle
Laurent qui a roué là qui m'a amené à la
gare aujourd'hui il roule en Renault oh
une Renault des années 80 R18 non non tu
sais les les celles qu'on le bout plat
là un peu là un peu longue sur le devant
une vieille Renault ben il la retape en
permanence je trouve ça plus efficace
que de s'acheter cinq bagnoles juste
après c'est vrai que sur la consommation
on a des choses à voir mais si tu veux
l'aspect
psychologique d'enlever les gueux des
centre-villes
ouais nous la France comment on en est
arrivé arrivé là ce ce racisme social
ouais ça dépend de quel centr-eville tu
parles euh roubé c'est construit très
différemment tu parles des métropoles
comme la métropole parisienne ouais ou
Lyon Grenoble nouroué parle c'est une
ville à partentière donc c'est pas une
banlieu de lillele si tu veux c'est une
ville céit elle la capitale euh bah
c'est simple en fait il faut s'assurer
que on est de la main d'œuvre dans la
métropole parce qu'il y a besoin de
beaucoup de main d'œuvre pas cher mais
par contre on veut pas qu'il soit mêlé à
nous nous je dis les gens qui possèdent
les grands apparts et cetera et de toute
façon le prix de l'immobilier l'en
empêche donc il faut qu'il soit pas trop
loin mais pas trop près donc tu vas
créer ce qu'on appelle la banlieu qui
émologiquement veut dire lieu bannie
hein quand même la base c'est quand même
un truc on a tendance à l'oublier mais
mais mais c'est comme ça que ça se fait
et vu que les prix de l'immobilier par
exemple en région parisienne deviennent
de plus en plus fort bah les gens sont
repoussé de plus en plus loin puis
maintenant ils habitent tu vois avant
ils habitaient moi j'ai grandi au l
ouais AC Ray euh de plus en plus long an
et maintenant même tu as des
populations qui sont dans des dans des
campagnes maintenant en fait tu vois
tellement en fait ça repousse en terme
de point de de parce qu'ils ont pas
d'argent pas beaucoup d'argent et et
pour aller bosser Tu es sur des horaires
moi je trouve que la forme urbaine c'est
un truc qu'on pense pas assez en
politique pour le coup la forme urbaine
des choses tu sais que fut un temps par
exemple il y avait des notamment après
la Seconde Guerre mondiale ils avaient
fait des des choses où pour le coup ça
c'est de l'administration quelque part
de la bureaucratie mais qui est utile il
y avait des bureaux
d'ts ça c'était un c'était quelque chose
que je trouvais intéressant des gens qui
réfléchissaient au temps de la vie et
qui essayit de contrôler des flux qui
essay de contrôler des activités qui
essay d'orienter en tout cas des choses
on un commissariia au plan ouais bah
roué c'est on a un premier ministre
roubé c'est mieux que berou et et et
ouais il y a un commissariat au plan qui
mais qui qui a rien commissionné du tout
d's je comprends pas comment on accepte
ça et ça ement c'est ce que je te disais
c'est un peu la bureaucratie qui qui
s'entretient elle-même quoi en fait tu
vois tu tiens je t'ai créé une case
vas-y je' créé un placard ouais petit
placard tu as un chauffeur ou je sais
pas je sais pas ce à quoi il avait droit
donc je vais pas mais bon clairement tu
as des avantages pour un bou tu fut rien
quoi la transition énergétique ça marche
aussi dans dans les communes et tout
c'està-dire tu as des jetons de
participation tu sais dans des conseils
de surveill ça marche partout des trucs
de jetons de participation dans des
conseils de surveillance ça serait très
bien que les élus soient assdus
là-dedans quand ils y sont moi perso
j'ai fait le choix d'être dans aucun de
conseil de surance j'ai pas le temps
donc je vais pas faire un truc que tu
vois la transition énergétique vous
roulez tout c électrique pour je sais
plus quel 2030 interdiction des
véhicules thermiques euh moi il y a un
truc qui me fait très peur c'est la
question du rendement énergétique en
fait parce que il est quelle heure en
fait là parce que faut pas que je ratete
mon train non plus non mais tu as un
train quelle heure tu as dit que au bout
d'une heure si je te faisais chier tu
partes au bout d'une heure je pense que
ça va ouais mais tu me fais pas trop
chier donc ça va il est à 21h40 c'est le
dernier train tu es baisé tu dors à
Paris ce soir il est 21h25 il ah ouais
non là tuabuses ah non ben on a pas vu
le temps passer [__] ouais mais je
dois nourrir mes chasses c'est ça le
problème oh merde euh tu à quelle heure
TU la Guerre du Nord 21h45 je crois
ouais bah il va falloir qu'on coupe dans
une minute il faut que tu t'arraches
direct 15 minutes pour monter he ok donc
je te réponds très vite ouais j'ai j'ai
j'ai peur de la question du rendement
énergétique c'estàdire que le pétrole a
un rendement énergétique de fou il
propulse les machines il propuls tout
l'électricité moi je je je suis pas
assez technicien mais j'ai pas
l'impression que ça soit la même chose
par exemple pour les voitures et cetera
par ailleurs dans la construction des
voitures électriques va y avoir un petit
souci en terme d'indépendance aussi
c'està dire que moi je veux bien qu'on
passe au tout électrique mais il va y
avoir un souci parce que en fait les
batteries elles sont faites en Chine
aussi quoi
donc en tout cas faut pas dire aux gens
que tu fais des véhicules électriques
parce que c'est l'autonomie française
parce qu'il y a des usines qui sont dans
le Nord qu'on ouvert pour certaines
d'entre elles ça ça ne marchera pas moi
je n'y crois pas
euhon il va falloir que tu reviennes
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de questions
euh je vais te lâcher tout de suite
parce que par c'est j'ai pas vu le temps
ça fait combien de temps qu'on est là ça
fait 2h1 minutes ah quand même
euh tu vas revenir ok trois livres à
conseiller je reviens quand je suis mer
de roubé c'est ton
problème trois livres à conseiller tu
sais même pas si tu vas être maire de
rouet
donc je vais essayer de l'être TR livres
à conseiller toute gamme confondu qui
ont été importants pour toi pour ton
cheminement intellectuel qui qui tr TR
livres importants pour les gens pour
notre communauté ok alors
pourdieu sur la télévision c'est ce que
j'avais lu quand j'étais en j'étais en
seconde ou en terminale et je comprenais
rien à l'époque mais en fait ce qu'il a
dit était visionnaire sur la circulation
circulaire de l'information et tout donc
j'avais du Bourdieu je suis tenté de
dire One Piece mais
bon va fallir qu'a ce sujet là moi il y
a des mangas et des choses qui m'ont
profondément influencer en fait hein
c'est un gars quand même qui part faire
le tour du monde pour libérer tous les
peuples opprimés c'est quand même assez
sympa comme histoire de masse pour des
générations à venir après en terme il y
a un truc qui m'avait marqué mais en
fait je suis pas d'accord au final
c'était leur morale et la nôtre de
Trotski parce que mais je me rendais pas
compte à l'époque c'est un livre très
dur assez violent tu vois en gros c'est
la fin justifie les moyens politiques ce
avec quoi moi je suis revenu dessus mais
qui a d'une beauté aussi parce Queen
fait il venait de se faire assassiné son
fils quand il écrit ça euh et c'est un
livre ouais qui m'a qui m'a un peu
marqué quand même sur à quel point il
dévoile la violence de la morale de ceux
qui sont face à nous la limite de ce
livre c'est qu'il ne te donne pas une
morale en retour et sinon allez un
dernier euh parce que One Piece c'était
un peu pour rigoler enfin c'était pas
que pour rigoler mais il y a un livre
aussi qui m'avait beaucoup plus c'était
Fernand brodel l'identité de la France
euh
on avait énormément de questions sur
l'écologie nos infrastructures le
réchauffement climatique si ça allait
tenir si on est designé pour on avait
des questions sur l'immigration sur le
conflit israëlpalestinien et ainsi suite
ah ouais euh le tout électrique et ainsi
de suite donc c'est 2 Hees trop
court un conseil pour les jeunes
générations quelque chose d'impérissable
j'ai envie de direbl de réfléchir non je
te jure que en fait j'hésite enas un
truc tu vois très politique ou un truc
plus personnel en fait et je peux faire
les deux mais fais le vite parce que tu
es un train à prendre après c'est tonou
mais je dirais plutôt pour les jeunes
qui nous écoutent c'est n n'ai jamais
honte de courir après le bonheur de
penser un peu à toi tu vois tu es
légitime à faire ça on on vit dans un
monde où tu vois faut se sacrifier pour
tout sauf pour soi-même et les sien et
moi courir comme un poulet sans tête tu
vois moi j'ai j'arrête là-dessus mais
moi une des chances que j'ai eu c'est
quand j'ai perdu ma grand-mère j'ai eu
le temps de l'accompagner jusqu'à la fin
ouais les soins palliatifs c'est hyper
important j'ai eu le temps et j'ai vu
par exemple quand je la voyais elle
était heureuse en fait il y a pas que la
santé physique qui compte tu vois et et
et surtout quand elle est partie moi ça
a été un arrachement tu vois je porte
encore son anneau et tout mais mais je
me suis dit j'ai pas de regret et et et
je me suis aussi dit mais il y a des
gens qui ont des regrets parce que tu
vois dans la vie tu as pas le temps de
t'occuper de ta mère ou de ta grand-mère
et moi j'aimerais bien en fait que enfin
mon modèle de société c'est un modèle où
tu as le temps de prendre soin des
autres c'est pas c'est une revendication
politique qui s'organise qui s'organise
mais avec un peu de discipline
collective et et d'envie j'y crois voilà
parce que parce que il y a il y a des
choses plus importantes que M trop
boulot dodo pour moi voilà David merci
merci à toi et et à la prochaine à la
prochaine salut
[Musique]